joe biden was uh questioned
by uh fox news's ducey about three
statements he had made which were
particularly egregious and he claimed it
never happened he's he implied there
would be u.s troops going into ukraine
that the u.s would use chemical weapons
and that joe biden wanted regime change
in russia and biden's like that never
happened what are you talking about
this is uh this is absolutely crazy news
cycle because not only did he deny it he
then doubles down on calling for regime
changing russia and then when ducey says
like what do you mean you'll respond in
kind of chemical weapons he was i'm not
telling you and he's like the people
want to know and he's like well i'm not
telling him
just wow tremendous response from a
president so you know we'll we'll be
talking about that plus uh florida has
signed ronda sanders has signed into law
the don't say straight bill that's right
the bill in florida which prevents
teachers from talking to uh preschoolers
to kinder third graders about
heterosexual marriage
it really does of course the the media
and the left have been framing us that
don't say gay bill but we'll get in all
that stuff and then ladies and gentlemen
we have a extra juicy bit of drama
tonight
you see on november 2nd 2020
i released the first song in a series
called will of the people where you see
a ground shot of the base of a statue
moving up with cables thrown over it
under an orange sky and then people pull
the rope down
while saying this is the will of the
people and something interesting
happened muse on my birthday march 9
published a video call uh for their
album will of the people and song will
of the people that starts with a ground
shot and then you see a foot come in and
then it shows a a low view up to a
statue with cables hanging from it under
an orange sky while people are chanting
will of the people and i've gotten a lot
of questions about it and a lot of
people are asking me what does it mean
what did my tweet mean what's going to
be happening and uh
wow this is really crazy this is a crazy
story and i feel like i'm in a very
difficult position here so i'll just
give you just a brief a quick mention is
uh
most of you have been following the show
know that we've invested a significant
sum of money uh six figures into our
will of the people universe
i've mentioned repeatedly we have a
sequel we actually have several because
this is part of a concept universe
following these ideas that we talk about
the show in song form we've talked about
graphic novels and i shouldn't have to
reveal our plans for these characters
we've already storyboarded out two
sequels to the to the song as part of
the series we've already had plans for
um
we've already discussed uh film
and so we're we're very heavily
investing in cultural development so
we'll get into all of that but suffice
it to say this is a serious problem for
us but we'll talk about what it means
and i'll show you guys what it is
because some people have questions about
legal issues and i'll just uh uh add one
one last thing to let people understand
we're not some fly by night company
we're not just like some that we're in
we're in a six-figure studio this is a
you know expensive construction in a
multi uh in a in a
million dollar property like we are a
big company in terms of our reach and
everything we have a ton of lawyers that
handle all of this stuff for us and it's
shocking that we're in this position but
here we are so that being said we'll get
into all the news joining us to uh talk
about all this is alex breusowitz did i
get it right you got right all right man
i was worried about like i'm going to
say it wrong
how do you pronounce your last name uh
it's puawl
is it french
yes or ukrainian it's actually dutch oh
it's dutch okay yeah yeah but uh thanks
for coming man you want to introduce
yourself i'm alex bruce wits i'm a
victim of the unconstitutional january 6
commission witch hunt and uh you know
i'm i'm a real victim real life victim
now i'm a political consultant i own a
company called x strategies i know
you've had greg price on a couple of
times and he loves you guys and i've
been a fan of yours for for a couple
years so really grateful to be here and
thank you for the opportunity absolutely
man we got a lot of fun stuff to talk
about we also have our good friend
sheamus
oh well i am james but i'm filling in
for ian crossland so i'm going to do my
best to be an ian's substitute uh this
evening however i will let you all know
if you're interested in seeing more of
my content i run a youtube channel
called freedom tunes where we upload
animated cartoons every thursday
sometimes on tuesdays as well go check
it out very cool you guys know it is my
favorite night of the week that is
monday night because i enjoy my job very
much very happy to be here with alex
stoke to get into it tonight let's go i
know everybody's also like please don't
talk about chris rock getting slapped
but it was staged no maybe maybe
maybe we'll talk about it before we get
started my friends head over to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you can pick
up your keto elevate
c8mct oil powder 51 off this is medium
chain triglyceride keto oil powder if
you are trying to cut the carbs and you
want energy this is what you want to get
i like mixing it in my coffee it's uh
it's like creamy it's like it's it's
really really nice it doesn't uh doesn't
taste like anything too crazy it just
kind of creams up your coffee but you
can put in smoothies and put in anything
and many of you know i've been doing
like i i i was doing keto for a while
and then i kind of eased off i'm just
doing like a real low carb thing and
this stuff's fantastic go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you get a
60-day money-back guarantee keto elevate
provides your body only c8 the most
ketogenic mct that means it provides
support for energy levels healthy
appetite management mental clarity and
focus athletic performance keto elevates
personally my favorite mct
free shipping on every order and for
every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you will also get free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust's team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order so
thank you so much biotrust for
sponsoring the show that's
eatrightandfeelwell.com
but don't forget to go to timcast.com
and become a member if you would like to
support our work directly as a member
you get access to our exclusive segments
from this show which go up monday
through thursday at 11 pm we'll have one
of those members only episodes for you
guys tonight and we also have a green
room episode these are fridays once a
week where you get to see us just
hanging out downstairs in our green room
with our guests and as you can see we
have jeremy boring co-ceo of the daily
wire who was hanging out downstairs we
got pool table we got movies video games
and it looks like uh sheamus is there
playing exact guy that's the actor who
played ian crossland on tim cast when he
was
right and i'll also point out in this i
think there's also uh uh the video game
that seamus and i are working on yeah
and tim cassin sheamus is very excited
about it so you might get some i don't
know i don't know what we're allowed to
release about the video game we're
working on yeah we're trying to we're
trying to keep as much of it under wraps
as we can but i'm pretty pumped for it
we've been working on it for a while we
got video games we got books the next
book from tales from the inverted world
is coming soon we've got a bunch of
music already in the works and i have it
on my phone we're thinking within the
next month or two we might have another
full music video so we're we're cranking
all this cultural stuff so we take it
seriously all right so don't forget to
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's read this first story from the
daily mail biden stands by his comment
that putin cannot remain in power but
insists he was expressing moral outrage
not policy change claims three russia
gaffes didn't happen despite white house
having to walk them back
i i gotta show you the video everybody
we nee you need to watch this because um
i'm sitting i'm sitting downstairs
i i get a message from cassandra
fairbanks mcdonald and she's like you
need to watch this video no no like no
laughing and lol anything was like watch
this and then i watch it and we're just
playing it on the counter and then all
of a sudden we get to this point where
everyone in the room busts out laughing
and i'm just like we are screwed come on
man let me let me let me play this clip
for you guys and then we'll we'll
oh wait let me fix the audio for you you
know it's funny because before the show
started i was browsing twitter i didn't
get a chance to do that today it's very
necessary and i saw your tweet with that
biden video and i was cracking up i
didn't want to interrupt your
conversation there oh i was like we are
screwed yeah all right let's see if we
got it hopefully it's loud enough are
you worried that other leaders in the
world are going to start to doubt that
america is back if some of these big
things that you
say on the world stage keep getting
walked back
what's getting walked back it made it
sound like just in the last couple days
uh it sounded like you told us troops
they were going to ukraine
it sounded like you said it was possible
the us would use a chemical weapon and
it sounded like you were calling for
regime change in russia and we know
none of the three occurred
none of the three none of the three mr
president you interpret the language
that way i was talking to the troops
we're talking about helping train the
troops in that are the the ukrainian
troops that are in poland that's with
the context i sat there with those guys
for a couple hours that's what we talked
about
so when you said you're going to see
when you're there you were not intending
i was referring to with
meeting with and talking with the uh
ukrainian troops who were in poland and
when you said a chemical weapon used by
russia would trigger a response in time
it will trigger a significant response
i'm not going to tell you
[Laughter]
what the world wants to know the world
wants to know a lot of things i'm not
telling them what the response would be
then russia knows the response
that was amazing also i want to say i
just love how it starts with this
reporter talking to him like he's five
years old it's like the exact cadence
and tone of voice you used to speak to a
child with god bless peter ducey he's
been great this entire uh regime so far
he's going to be really important next
couple years too yeah it's it's crazy
how
the guy from fox news is the only one
questioning the president look if if you
know when you have a president trump
you get a journalist who's like trump i
got to push back i want to answer i want
some questions answered i'll be like you
know we should have journalists pushing
back no matter what it is if if you know
trump could come out and give a good
answer and a journalist is like i'm
going to push back and i want you to
answer these these concerns i'm fine
with that but what did we get under
trump
every single journalist was just always
spitting and yelling and complaining and
very very unserious lies manipulations
chasing false stories now we get biden
arguably one of the worst presidents
we've ever had
who said
when you're there you're going to see
people in front of a damn tank refusing
to move it's like what does that mean
like troops are going to be there he
said if russia's chemical weapons will
respond in kind uh
is the u.s going to use chemical weapons
in ukraine well remember tim the adults
are back in charge that's what we heard
for four years we need to get the adults
back in charge and uh this is the best
that they have to offer i think yeah i
think we went too far to the upper
limits with that whole adult thing yeah
yeah i could have been a little younger
my favorite don junior post was he says
you're supposed to eat your vegetables
not elect them oh my gosh
and so that's what we have that right
here i mean he's completely lost it and
you know to your point
the media was so uh you know vicious
towards trump
and they would lie about him but now
they cover for their lies and they'll
actually run stories about how joe biden
didn't actually say what he said this is
what he actually meant and so it's a
total double standard and it's complete
bs we saw lindsey graham
call for the assassination of vladimir
putin and i was like yo i call him lady
g uh so there was a report a couple
years back about lindsey graham lady g
about how he had relationships with a
bunch of men
and the establishment would say alex you
can't call lindsey graham lady g it's
going to be hard for us to recommend
senators to work with you and that's
okay so i doubled down on lady g and so
he's
is he drunk when he goes on hannity
calling for the assassination it's the
same thing here and so uh it's
who's running the messaging of this it's
it's so i bring him up because now biden
is saying you know what what did he said
quote for god's sake this man cannot
remain in power
and i'm just like
wow
you want to talk about no peace
no chance at any kind of resolution here
you can thank lindsey graham and then
you can thank the president because
yo
vladimir putin's going to be like okay
there is absolutely no reason to
communicate at all with the americans
yeah we know their position so that you
know i'm not a military expert by any
means okay but uh i've been in a few
fights in my life or have seen some
fights happening and i think the number
one goal should be to de-escalate right
and the adults in charge currently have
no interest in de-escalating why because
the people who fund their campaigns and
fund their livelihoods uh something
called the military industrial complex
and say no de-escalation you guys are
pushing for war we're sending in the
migs and like i said nobody knows what
the hell a mig is but everybody's
sending in tweets in all caps sending
the migs and so i don't want to send in
the migs i want to send in the piece
yeah it's hilarious uh you know the
adults who are in charge completely fail
to understand that there is a concrete
world that exists outside of their
rhetoric and politics doesn't just exist
on twitter or on television and the
things they say to foreign leaders or
about leaders are actually going to have
consequences beyond their constituents
liking them more or throwing red meat to
their fan base or the right people
disliking them i mean calling for the
assassination of a foreign leader online
while they're invading another country
and tensions are as high between us and
them as they've ever been or for the
president of the united states to say
that the leader of a nuclear power needs
to be removed from his position is so
unbelievably out of line and insane and
irresponsible but of course they're the
grown-ups right and we constantly heard
about how trump had mean tweets and
trump wasn't responsible with the things
that he said but you know what things
were somewhat together at that point and
these people are literally not at all
different except
trump's policies were actually somewhat
effective
i like how trump would you know they
accused him of
working with dictators
then i'm just like if it brought peace
it was i can't remember who who was i
don't want to quote the wrong person but
he was like you got to understand the
reason putin didn't invade ukraine under
trump was because trump was doing his
bidding right what the hell does that
even mean it's so stupid i'm like
pulling out how does that make sense
pulling our troops out of syria okay i
guess like so what you're saying is
donald trump was de-escalating war and
crushing isis so putin was like all
right i'm a chill yeah should he not
have done that i mean we should i guess
if it makes putin happy we shouldn't do
it but this is why it was a perfect and
beautiful life i got it what is it if we
really want to piss off putin then we
just need to to stand back while isis
comes back
that'll show that that russian that's
true
so i've been doing a lot to to you know
support ukraine i've banned moscow meals
in my home
i'm not doing white russians anymore uh
in fact i'm just gonna dump out every
bala vodka i own um and if you're not
doing stuff to help ukraine each day you
have to check yourself before you wreck
yourself uh because ukraine is like my
total everything now can i ask you
something um what's your policy on cats
that were bred in russia competing in
cat shows yeah i want to make sure you
really have a sufficiently tough
response to their aggressiveness yeah i
don't think that should be allowed you
know we can take serious measures we
should ban russian cats from america
yeah okay i went to a yogurt restaurant
like a frozen yogurt place and they had
a chalkboard when you walked in and
someone drew the ukrainian flag on it
and i'm like the people working here are
like 16 years old and i i don't think
anything i i don't i don't think any of
them know where nowhere ukraine is no
they couldn't they couldn't point it out
if there was uh the letter u and a
picture of a crane next to it on a map
that's right pointing right to these i
love all the buildings lit up in like
blue and yellow and i wish people paid
this much attention to ukraine in
october of 2020 when it was reported
that hunter biden was getting paid big
money by barista but uh now everybody's
ukraine expert ukraine stan adam
kinzinger is you know fawning over
zilinski shirtless every day on twitter
um
if you came to me and you were like
joe biden actually has a gigantic mind
control device and the reason he always
seems out of it in titus because he he's
like professor x and he's just exhausted
himself and he's mind controlling people
into believing fake news i'd be like
well
you know
there's been so many fake stories and
people keep believing it that almost
sounds like a plausible explanation
biden's got a mind control device
because i don't i don't understand how
you can have millions of people in this
country
like one day all of their all their
twitter accounts have blue hats then all
their twitter accounts have syringes
then all their twitter accounts have
ukraine flags yeah and like no matter
how many fake stories come out they just
like yeah i'm gonna go along with
whatever whatever they say or like it
was it bill burr when he's talking to
joe and he was like i just turn on the
news once every two weeks and do they
tell me to do yeah i'm like man oh boy
is that someone's got to have mind
control powers i swear thinking's hard
it's it's hard to think and people
have whatever the hell they got going on
they had their fantasy football leagues
that they got to pay attention to or
they have their netflix series they
really tuned into doing the real
critical thinking about the important
issues it's hard they just want to you
know listen to the experts right and the
experts are
bought and paid for unfortunately by
people who
don't want to do the right thing how
many how many days do you think it'll be
until some you know fact checker
publishes an article saying tim poole
claims joe biden has mind control powers
yeah one day
yeah absolutely like in tim insanely
claims joe biden has mind control powers
because they don't know what sarcasm or
joke is or if they're good
or if they're really meta they'll
release an article saying tim poole
falsely claims we're going to release an
article about him making false claims
about joe biden's mind control powers
you're onto something there seamus thank
you thank you so the whole well one
thing i wanted to mention here is when
we look at the scenario when we look at
the fact that trump was called a
puppet for putin every single time he
did something that russia might at the
very least appreciate or which wasn't um
you know explicitly aggressive towards
them we were told he was a puppet this
is exactly why russiagate was the
perfect lie for the deep state in the
industrial military complex to fabricate
about a sitting president of the united
states because they've been trying to
push for war with russia for years now
and all you have to say is well the
current president is being controlled
and anytime he doesn't want to go to war
with them anytime doesn't want to do
anything that would lead to war with
them it's because he's a puppet it's
because he's weak do you guys see this
tweet we have this from gordon leubold
all right this guy is a white house
national security and pentagon reporter
for the wall street journal yeah he says
leon panetta says on cnn that biden's
gaffe in europe about regime change came
about because biden is irish
and his instinct to internalize human
suffering may have overwhelmed him to
the point where he was not careful about
what he says
biden needs more discipline panetta says
what's he talking about
is he saying there's some sort of
internalized irish thing that exists
within ethnically irish people causes
them to respond a certain way alex are
you irish i'm not irish oh okay well i
could self-identify though yeah that's
true that's true yeah all right well i
did on the 17th yeah wait this is i'm
assuming this is satirical though
you're sitting right now i'm going to be
ian today
tell me about this deep irish uh
internalization of suffering wait i want
to be clear this is a joke right
no come on
are you serious oh my gosh i would have
used this to get out of so much trouble
in school i know right i'd have been
like you know what i'll turn my homework
in when uh ireland is a free nation not
being occupied by the british is that
what they're claiming yeah i have no
clue what what is this
i'm sorry
this is this has to be a joke you're
messing with me i don't know is it a
joke is it for real i don't know it's
this is a wall street journal reporter
tweeting it out i i agree with you i'd
assume you know even if it's not a joke
it's a joke you know what i mean yeah
it's ridiculous it's a great statement i
mean
the spin's amazing are we an oppressed
group now who gets to use that as is
like an excuse for failure the irish
have always been oppressed in my opinion
it's true well no i mean irish people
weren't like considered white until
being white meant you had to apologize
for being white absolutely so frankly
you know talk about uh reparations
buying high and selling low i'm just
thinking about how we're going to title
this thumbnail like this clip and it's
going to be like sheamus outrage
responds outrage to racism i guess cnn
claims joe biden is oppressed because
he's irish yes or something like that
it's gonna be good i don't but i don't i
wrote a book called anglo fragility and
it's about how
if you don't think you have anglo
privilege it's because you've
internalized it more deeply than other
people and when i make mistakes and you
point that out it's actually because you
are spitting upon the graves of my
ancestors for holding me accountable
irish i didn't see that one coming yeah
i can't believe that i think that it
would be really great if they used an
excuse for anything biden does he's
irish come on
so this is remember well this is
interesting because you remember during
the state of the union when i said he
sounds drunk
he's always irish
you broke a good point about the russia
gate scenario as well and and it's
important lindsey graham was on cnn
shortly after the 2020 uh 2016 election
and he did an interview talking about
how russia also hacked his emails and
that's why he got one percent of the
primary vote now he got one percent of
the primary vote because his failed
dangerous policies were horrible and
widely rejected
and also because he's lindsey graham
nobody likes this guy so he's had a
personal bone to pick with putin for a
long time he blames his own failures on
on putin he should take some
self-accountability and seek help i want
to make two points here firstly everyone
argues well my emails were hacked by a
nefarious group who you shouldn't trust
okay but those were your emails we're
talking about things you actually said
you can't like putin did not put those
words in your mouth but also we went
from the president as a russian puppet
to the president is an irish puppet his
internalized uh suffering as an irishman
irish gate that's resulted remember when
someone someone commented
that not also like really really
offensive that's extremely racist
towards he is
i i know but that's extremely like oh
well of course he's going to make
mistakes he's sorry you know like i'm
sore
of course he said something ridiculous
and needlessly aggressive that he didn't
need of course he picked a fight that he
didn't need to get in his iris whenever
whenever biden slurs or stumbles can we
just say he's irish he's irish watch out
you know what the implication of that
would be but look look someone replied
is this related somehow to cuomo's i'm
irish defense
that was cuomo's i'm italian defense
yeah when he posted all those videos of
him grabbing people and kissing them and
he was like see look it's normal i do it
all the time that's what the top comment
is in italian giving advice on
self-discipline question mark question
mark yeah like are you guys here this is
not a joke um fox just released an
article that says former obama defense
secretary president biden made putin
gaffe because he's quote irish please
hold on can you can i read this tweet
again i'm sorry i'm not off this yet but
we'll get back to it don't worry oh
there we go so we got the actual article
i mean this is what can you expect from
him
yeah there you go
he strikes again oh my god
it's amazing
new epigenetic trauma is a mainstream
smart person concept data point just
dropped
true all right um
joe biden is in europe
making gaffe after gaff
implying that u.s troops would be in
ukraine the white house then goes no no
no no no
then saying if putin uses chemical
weapons we respond in kind no no no no
no no
then he says we need regime change you
know what i'll i'll take it and then
they're like
cnn then comes out they sign out the
white house oh it's because he's irish
and he's internalizing the suffering of
the ukrainian people he's like his sweet
little irish feelings were too
overwhelming to him he's not in control
of himself is it is this like a point no
no for real i have a serious question
though is is are they making some kind
of point about ukraine being like
northern ireland like the donbass region
is northern ireland and russia is like
the uk you know what i mean i think
they're just calling irish people stupid
yeah
i'm pretty sure that's what's happening
here they're like look joe biden joe
biden doesn't have dementia he's irish
that's what's happening right now do you
understand shame
irish victim be a victim no well look
this guy is giving me victim points he's
saying that irish people are more likely
to internalize other people's suffering
yeah i mean it makes it sound like very
nice and empathetic i get that but
it's i don't know a little bit offensive
you know oh by the way i'm trying to
make myself a victim tim every single
time you say something insulting about
the irish people you you pull the irish
card out and say oh i'm part irish dude
so really tim you're being insulted as
well what am i i think i'm like a third
irish or something
i'm german so
you know no empathy there yeah no
empathy from me
no empathy for me i am german irish and
korean and there's like uh and like a
little bit of a bunch of stuff like my
last name is dutch i guess
but uh yeah absolutely i'm wondering
it's like the germans and the irish like
team up for something because like
german irish tends to be like everything
i mean we both drink drinking beer
germany is actually a pretty common mix
yeah
german people and irish people were like
yeah i think those were just i think
those were just like the poor immigrants
at the turn of the century yeah right
that sounds like the 1900s late 1800s it
was the irish of the germans and they
hung out and
but no i think there's something i do
think there's something to this there do
you guys remember biden's whole like
pot of gold gaff
we're going to pay off of course we're
going to be able to pay off the national
debt but they've got to be punched of
gold at the other end of the rainbow his
economic plan to follow rainbows until
we could get the gold at the end of them
do you guys not recall that the
buildback better plan yeah yes exactly
there was a no no no in all seriousness
in all seriousness though there was that
one moment where he was chasing after
all those little kids yeah because uh
that's right because he sniffs them they
said they're after me lucky charms no i
wasn't telling you i actually wasn't
going for that joke i was going for the
biden sniffs little kids really that's
not a joke it's a real problem
that should not be tolerated is it not
i'll i'll leave it alone in a second
because i know we've really harped on
this but i just got to say is it that
hard to admit the man's experiencing
cognitive decline he makes a gaffe
because he always makes gaffes and
they're like you know what the guy's
irish because yeah you know
or always with leon panetta is like
biting gaffes and they're just looking
in the hat of random defenses of biden
and there's like one left and says irish
on he's like
because he's wish me luck
well i think it's important to remember
that obama's former secretary of defense
robert gates said quote biden's been
wrong in every foreign policy decision
in his entire career
and so there's there's no excuses for
the guy just sucks at his job he's been
in in office for 50 years and he's been
wrong on everything and so nobody has
confidence in his ability to get us
through this i got to push back on that
man uh that is that is unfair biden has
not been wrong in every foreign policy
decision he's made uh incredibly uh
successful decisions as it pertains to
foreign policy for his family oh yeah
you know the contract is brother god i
gotta say like like arming the irish
rebels
the job yeah the jobs that his uh his
kid
got uh i think i think you're looking in
the wrong place you're right so we can
say that joe biden has failed the
american people in terms of foreign
policy but the joe biden personal family
foreign policy is quite successful i
mean to be honest though i could not i
could not believe it when he armed the
ira yeah
that was really i thought that was
pushed too far
it was very shocking it's funny but like
i am that sounds like something that
could be true actually because he's been
in office for so long like actually in
the late 80s early 90s biden signed this
bill
stated he's like come on man we're going
to give credit guns guns to the ira man
get ready
get rid of the brits
i got a brand new shiny helmet and a
pair of kinky boots man but i don't
remember the last presidential election
where foreign policy wasn't really at
the forefront yeah and because of
president trump's success for four years
we had peace all across the board peace
in the middle east peace in korea uh you
know russia was at bay china was
obviously doing what they do to you know
unleash the virus under the world uh but
the foreign policy aspect wasn't really
a conversation during the 2016 2020
debate when it was at the forefront of
2016 one but who's going to destroy isis
and everybody thought that trump was
going to be the one that actually did it
and he succeeded
but this is in foreign policy was a
negligent issue in the 2020 debate and
if you could have played that clip of
robert gates saying that he's been wrong
on every foreign policy decision and
there's actually foreign policy
conflicts
i think that would have had a a you know
drastic impact but we're seeing the
genius at work here and and what
happened in afghanistan what's happened
in ukraine china's going to move on
taiwan it's going to be nasty and we got
this blabber and fool in office and
hunter biden's you know secure in the
bag they suspended the gas tax
so a bunch of people i've talked to
people out here in maryland and they're
like
uh they're like no gas prices went down
things got better and i was like yeah
they suspended the gas tax like gas
prices aren't going down the government
just backed off because they're scared
about what's happening and they went oh
they're like yeah because in west
virginia it's still over four dollars
but but don't worry uh biden brought in
the tick dockers to say to make tick
tocks calling it the putin gas hike or
gas price hike so it's on putin he says
and they all come in like good little
sheep and then they you know spit it out
to their audiences and uh it's really
sad how how quick this misinformation
can spread
blame putin i mean he's russian right
all right my friends you all saw the
state of the union i assume because we
were here and we were drinking and
lauren southern was drunk and she yelled
and called biden based because he said
we got to secure the border that's true
uh so the reason i bring that up in the
context of this story about biden's new
billionaires tax is that joe biden
during the state of the union says he's
a capitalist
secure our borders
build built make it make america you
know build american
now after that's long past he comes out
with this far left 20 minimum tax on
households worth more than a hundred
million dollars this is a trojan horse
marked by words
regular people are going to be like why
do i care i don't make 100 million
dollars
two things they will lower the threshold
like they did with the income tax
initially what was the initial the
initial income tax is like three percent
only for the ultra wealthy right and
then of course they just move it down
move it down move it down but this is
also joe biden desperately pandering to
the far left after calling himself a
capitalist he's like
i wonder if they're doing a media
strategy of okay state of the union was
this big tv thing that old people watch
say what the old people want to hear now
internet medium put out a statement
that's what the left wants to hear the
progressives so he's going to tax the
rich
they say 20 minimum tax on unrealized
gains
so elon musk that this is this is the
craziest thing it's basically like if
you buy
check this out used cars have gone up in
value like crazy because the chip
shortage
let's say this tax was a general tax on
everybody unrealized gains tax you buy a
used car for two grand but then the chip
shortage hits and now the value of used
cars in all government metrics is up a
hundred percent
your two thousand dollar car is now four
thousand dollars the government goes you
got two thousand dollar unrealized gain
right there and you say well i don't
have any money i just have my used car
and they say then you gotta sell the car
yep to pay the tax you say but if i sell
the car then i won't be able to work and
they're like then you're gonna be in
trouble for not paying your taxes so you
sell the car guess what you could only
get a couple grand for the car and they
say now you owe us taxes on the income
you got from that two grand
and you're like so i got to pay the tax
on the unrealized gain but then i sold
the car now i got to pay taxes on the
income
right now it's 100 million dollars
but rest assured you give them the
ability to tax unrealized gains two
things are going to happen one the lower
threshold and the second is inflation
will push you up further and further to
that threshold yeah no it's true this is
one of the most insane economic policies
that he could try to implement right now
first of all we're not in a place where
you can really talk about introducing
these like radical new measures to
socialize the economy first of all we're
not really in a healthy place so to look
at these sort of more social justice-y
far-left pandering
options for policy and try to implement
them as ridiculous but also what this
effectively does tim you know you're
using the example of a used car
it would force people who are
successfully running businesses to the
point of making them profitable to sell
off their shares so basically somebody
who is moving a company in the direction
of making it more profitable is forced
to give up control of their company so
they can pay the tax on unrealized gains
and what an unrealized gain is by the
way
is money you literally have not made
it's completely theoretical the
government is taxing something you don't
have yeah and and they could they could
theoretically just be like hey sheamus
that shirt a million bucks yeah i mean
exactly how do you like what's the value
of something like that i mean hunter
buying's uh art uh assessor is going to
assess the value of all this stuff
exactly right well that's that's a big
trick too people people don't understand
that you're going to all of a sudden see
billionaires being like that rembrandt
painting
unfortunately nobody wants to buy it
anymore because of the tax so it's only
worth a thousand dollars i actually lost
that money can you write off the
unrealized losses yeah well i i also i
mean i'll give the
the regime uh some credit for
recognizing the moment that we're in uh
i think now more than ever there's an
appetite on both sides of the political
aisle to kind of stick it to some of
these uh billionaires and uh on the
right they're sick of the woke
billionaires who fund all these you know
these non-profits the arabellums that
help fortify elections against us and so
there's a appetite to take it to the to
the billionaire class that uh our people
the trump base i mean we're working
class folks um and and so the
billionaires don't have the same luster
and we don't have the same party anymore
and so there is an appetite there i
think
uh to get some on the on the more
populist right to jump on board with
something on this nature but tim you
bring up a good point where they're not
going to stop there if we give the
government an inch they're going to take
it down to you know the the half a
millionaires to the eventually anybody
that makes 100 100 grand will be
impacted by it or in 50 years when
inflation is really really bad and let's
say a dollar is now a dime so you're
spending 10 bucks on a candy bar you're
spending a hundred dollars you know on a
couple movie tickets or whatever
they also you know lowering the
threshold
and inflation is going to get you closer
and closer to that limit well i think
that the billionaires should wake the
hell up though especially you know the
ones that help fund these woke
institutions and the woke organizations
to get you know eat their esg scores
higher um because they're losing the
people that you know for historically
defended them they lose they're pissing
off a lot of republican voters who've
always been against the increase of
taxes they've been against the you know
the punishing the wealthy but when
you're using your wealth to fund
organizations that hate our country
it kind of pisses off some people and
they see stuff like that and like ah
well right now it's only for the
billionaires so maybe i'll support that
but you know what i think a lot of the
billionaires know that ultimately this
tax is going to disproportionately
affect wealthy people who aren't lucky
enough to be in the exact bracket that
billionaires are in and therefore will
have a more difficult time avoiding the
increased taxes on their net worth i'm
sure they'll find all sorts of
workarounds and loopholes so that they
don't end up having to pay and it will
actually make business more difficult
for their competition this is probably
good for that so i think it's probably
good for them take a look at like the
progressive tax brackets what's what's
the highest bracket is it 250 and up or
it's like 500. i need to double check i
think someone changed
yeah so imagine this it's like 37.5
imagine you're you're a middle-class you
know working-class person and uh you
you hit it big somehow and all of a
sudden you're making 400 dollars a year
which is a lot of money
you're paying a very high tax rate on
that two on everything above 250 which
is substantial it's you know what is it
like 40 was it 38 to 47 percent
yeah like 38 38.
if you're if you're worth if you're
making 10 million a year as like the ceo
of a company and you're paying that
percentage everything after 250 is
effectively disposable income for you to
invest any way you see fit
if you're making 250 to 400
you're like this is my chance to grow
and become a wealthy american but
they're pulling you down
so uh the simplest way to explain it is
if you only need in the united states
right now 150k a year to be considered
middle class median and that's because
of inflation used to be 77 000 and 80
and who knows where it's at now
once you hit that threshold
you're getting a savings you're building
a little bit of wealth but you're not on
track for independent wealth where you
can just dump money into a bunch of
funds and then make interest and things
like that you make 10 million dollars
who cares look i got my 250 a year to
fund my lifestyle and then i've got an
extra you know 9.75 million oh i got to
pay 38 i still got 5 million where i can
spend that on any anything i want and
generate massive amounts of wealth
as you as the richer you get the less
that impacts you so the long story short
of it is these taxes
stop people from becoming wealthy now
you tell that to the left you explain it
and they say good and i'm like no you
don't understand it means the
billionaires will stay billionaires
forever and they'll become oligarchs and
then no one can rise up and displace
them and challenge their power yeah
exactly and so another thing that he's
failing to take into account here and of
course he is because he's on the left is
a concept known as the laffer curve so
i've talked about this on your show
before and there are some less educated
lefties who will say the laffer curve
doesn't exist it does every left-wing
economist agrees it exists the only
debate is whether the parabola peaks at
a higher tax rate or a lower tax rate
basically yeah sure so if you tax at
zero percent your revenue will be zero
and if you tax it a hundred percent your
revenue will also be zero because no
one's going to work for money that they
can't keep so that means that somewhere
between zero percent and a hundred
percent
is the revenue maximizing tax rate at
which point you can reach it and then if
you tax any further you're actually
going to generate less revenue
and so interestingly federal revenues
for the united states have as a whole
have basically stayed around 20
regardless of what the tax rate has been
which suggests that's probably the
largest share of gdp
that they're able to pull and when i
said 22 i'm speaking as a share of gdp
so that's probably the largest share of
gdp they'll be able to pull out of the
economy so all they're going to be doing
with something like this if it even is
effective at getting these people to
sell off their wealth because again who
knows many of them are going to be able
to circumvent it but but let's say it
has its you know quote unquote intended
effect in that way
it's probably not going to increase
revenue i would argue that it wouldn't
increase revenue because the trump tax
cuts actually led to an increase in
revenue the left continually claims that
it didn't and biden talks about this you
know quote unquote fiscal mess that
trump left him but that's complete
nonsense federal revenues increased but
our spending growth outpaced the
increase in federal revenues so we ended
up with more of a deficit after the
trump tax cuts than we had prior but
that was because of an increase in
spending not a deficit in the amount
that we were bringing in
why we just print more print more money
bro yeah well you know yeah yeah yeah no
let's just do that that's worked
fantastically for us they're just
slapping band-aids on band-aids why
don't you start another trillion-dollar
war like multi-trillion dollar war let's
go let's go get a ground war with russia
like adam kinzinger and and lindsey
graham want and get some more money but
um
that seems like the direction things are
going i think a majority what is it a
majority of americans fear that the us
will get involved in a ground war with
russia it's terrifying especially i
couldn't think about the the parents who
you know have children who are active
duty and they all watch what the hell
happened in afghanistan and
thinking about the degenerates and the
morons who are in charge right now are
going to be in charge of the military uh
you know the operation on the ground
there
there's not a whole lot of confidence in
their ability to get the job done and so
praying that we can de-escalate and get
peace but um you know
it's just a mess let's talk about peace
here at home like can i mention one more
thing yeah
so you discussed you brought up biden
bingo which we played during the state
of the union address and i want to
mention that that headline starts with
biden whispers that it's not right which
was on the bingo card that we had that's
awesome by the state of union bingo he
likes to whisper daily mail has some
great headlines
let's let's talk about peace here at
home though we have this story ladies
and gentlemen florida's desantis has
signed the parental rights and education
bill hits back at hollywood critics
democrats misleadingly attacked florida
legislation as don't say gay bill i like
that fox news subhead accurately points
out that they've been lying the whole
time about what this bill does now
my understanding is the initial
inception of it was more so targeting
you know don't teach about gender
identity or whatever after several
amendments they came to okay how about
we just say
pre pre-k you know preschool to third
grade we don't want you teaching
identity and orientation stuff to
children to these nine to four four to
nine year olds after that it's fine just
keep it age-appropriate and for those
four-year-olds
as long as you talk to them in a
semi-private setting totally okay did
you know that
if in florida
this bill that was passed by republicans
will still allow a teacher to go up to a
four-year-old in a semi-private setting
meaning if if there's if they're in a
classroom there's a bunch of kids
running around
they're playing a teacher can get up and
walk over to a group of kids and say do
you want to learn about being trans oh
my god the bill does not ban that okay
and so that's what they've been they've
been claiming maybe we'll make some
calls into the florida legislature yeah
i mean it does again we were talking
about it being an anti-grooming bill but
it doesn't go nearly far enough to even
be called that yeah it's it i i call it
the don't say straight bill yeah because
the teachers also can't talk to these
kids about straight traditional marriage
so i'm gonna be asked the biggest pet
peeve i have with this whole outrage is
that when i was in high school just like
six years ago if i said gay in any
situation i get detention like alex you
can't say gay
and i tweet gay and now you know
congressmen who hate me they they find
screenshots of my tweets when i was 14
and i say the word gay in it he's a
homophobe
so you used to get in trouble if you
said the word gay and now you see these
idiots running through the halls of the
school yelling gay and getting no pink
slips no detention that's the bone i got
to pick with this bill primarily um
it's just i grew up in the wrong times
have you seen the meme where it's all
the disney where all the stories about
disney workers being arrested for child
exploitation oh absolutely that's
there's a great sheriff in that region
of florida named uh uh gary judge
sheriff judd he's phenomenal and i think
he busted like 17 disney workers for
like uh
pedophilia and trafficking kids it's a
sick i mean and also disney's so
outraged about banning sex ed from
young kids like this
i can guarantee when i have children
they will never watch disney what kind
of subliminal messaging and and crap do
they put in there whoa whoa you don't
know the urban legends about disney and
their subliminal sex oh yeah have you
seen that clip from the lion king oh
yeah which one is that one all good
girls take off their clothes oh um that
was aladdin so
that was the thing
when simba falls down onto the the um
flowers the pollen flies up into the air
and it spells the word sex and disney
claimed no no no it said sfx we were
excited about our new sound effects
package i'm not kidding what the hell
they said we were excited about our new
sound
package so we wrote sfx i'm sure we can
get like a higher def image or whatever
but that's weird there's also on the
cover of the little mermaid
oh yeah
is a large
um cylindrical
you know it's mental it's a mental
illness that they want to teach their
kids these kids about sex and they need
to be held accountable for and i think
desantis should reconsider the bill and
make it even tougher out of this
backlash
and also consider revoking some teaching
license from these these teachers who
are so uh enraged by it and who wants to
push their sexuality on these kids yeah
perverts yeah
sick perverts and the only people who
won't stand up against this are the
really sick perverts or they're complete
cowards because the responsibility of
adults is to protect children and as it
happens we live in a culture where
people are so fundamentally either
depraved or terrified and completely
weak that they would rather allow
children to be groomed than be called
homophobic or some other word that
everyone's too terrified to be labeled
with to actually stand up and protect
children against disgusting predators
this one might be
just you know people
wishful thinking i don't know about
wishful thinking but like
looking for something and then telling
everyone it's true so but let's see what
snopes has to say about this disney
thing right
was a phallus purposefully added to the
artwork of the little mermaid from 1998
false of course and you can see
it's just a golden tower of various you
know sizes and then uh what do we have
it here where did it go there you go
it's just
it's just a golden castle palace tower
and everybody i know would always point
this out and be like hey look what they
put on the cover
you also have um
what was it it was aladdin right uh when
when he was talking to uh uh
aladdin was talking to jasmine do you
know this one it sounds like yeah i i
remember the clip
and then also in the rescuers there was
an example i can't remember if it was
the rescuers or the rescuers down under
but as they fly uh past the series of
buildings there's actually a
pornographic image that's placed inside
one of the windows that's on camera for
a fraction of a second but it is there
here's snopes again did aladdin ask
teenagers to take off their clothes
false oh it's false sub says it good
teenagers take off your clothes
in the lad and he whispers it
so let's see can we play it are we gonna
get you two
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know man like trust disney maybe
maybe the lion king one is like they
really wanted to say sfx but uh
like
maybe
why even have it say anything right i
know
but but so anyway i bring up the disney
thing because it makes sense if like
these predators want to go to the to
these disney parks where there's kids
everywhere they're getting caught
what's fascinating to me is
maybe it's just coincidence that florida
says hey we don't want you talking to
kids about this stuff whether it's
straight or gay or otherwise
and then they're like oh oh harumph i
say how how dare do you tell us we can't
say gay and then they go around running
through the hallways and then it's like
also there's a ton of predators down
there at disney you know it's like a
coincidence no yeah well i mean we
talked about this uh a few shows ago but
brian peck was
hired to be a consultant on a disney
film after or on a disney project after
being found guilty of sexually abusing a
child oh man yeah there's some really
demented people out there and um
the outrage this bill and i'm glad that
you brought that point up how it doesn't
go far enough and if i know anything
about ron desantis he's going to want to
make sure it's even tougher and he's not
he's not going to cower to this outrage
he's going to
in fact probably double down but but
maybe
i mean the challenge is republicans are
consistently reasonable the democrats
accuse them of being vicious
authoritarians and look what they do
they're like you can still teach kids
about the stuff just not as a classroom
discussion
and and you know
it's it's like why are you giving leeway
there's no room to negotiate on this one
these are children yes uh they shouldn't
even be able to have these they
shouldn't even be allowed to have a
conversation period because this this
whole idea that you can change your
gender that should not be a conversation
that we ever normalize nor accept and so
the idea that some unqualified teacher
who's a creep is going to have this
conversation with your child you can't
let that happen and so but uh we we
can't be reasonable no leeway on this i
keep hearing from from parents who say i
can't speak up because i'd lose my job
and i'm just kind of like
it's kind of scary it's kind of scary
it's kind of a scary prospect that uh
you're more concerned about your job
than who your kid is around for eight
hours every day absolutely there's
another job out there and you know you
don't have that many kids maybe you do
imagine imagine being willing to work
for the kind of employer who would fire
you because you are against sexual
perverts trying to groom your child and
you're vocal about that yeah yeah
i think people need to hear
you can succeed i think people need to
hear that they're they're you you said
there are other jobs out there there was
what's that website for like anti-woke
people square something is that what it
was i don't know company square or
something yeah square's a payment
processing company square is a payment
but there's another yeah there's another
website you go to and it's like job
listings for people who aren't woke oh
yeah well god bless them we you got to
find that out and get to promote the
hell out of them i'm going to promote
them uh i mean
people need to have the courage to you
know stand up and say this stuff's
enough well people yeah i remember fire
and look i was in high school when when
uh gay marriage was legalized or you
know the supreme court ruling and i used
to i used to be like what's even the
fight about gay marriage like you know
the conservatives on their talk radio
would be like well if we normalize this
what else are we gonna be forced to
normalize i'm like oh they're just
bigots or whatever and then five years
later six years later uh somebody who
was a woman for four days gets named
sports illustrated woman of the year
caitlyn jenner and now we're in this
next phase of the the the transition
into normalizing stuff but the grooming
crap it's because there's there's no end
right they say the ends justify the
means but there is no end meaning no
matter where you are you're always
moving in one direction the issue is
for me it's not
it's it's it's not gay marriage or
slippery slope fallacy i think two
consenting adults is not the issue
obviously there's a lot of traditional
conservatives have issue with that i
disagree the issue is children
who can't consent that's always been the
point adults can consent because they're
they're you know they can go and do
their thing children cannot
it's i look at this like
there needs to be a hard line you i i
don't need to come and be like what's
next you know dogs and cats you know
living together or whatever no no i just
feel like you know i don't care about
consenting adults i care about this hard
line stop done have a nice day yeah you
know like who's phenomenal on this it's
an open secret that that twitter account
i think is open and i've gotten to know
the folks behind that pretty well and
they say we gotta stop talk using the
term child porn because porn's a
consenting term and children can't
consent it's her child it's child rape
and torture material uh and so i i try
not to use the term child porn uh in my
rhetoric because you can't when you're a
child you can't consent um and and
children can never consent we can never
normalize that and so we have to you're
right you have to stand up for the kids
um and the parents need to wake the hell
up uh and and and they need to be vocal
they need to be the ones that stop this
yeah i i want to make another point here
piggybacking off of what you just said
about all the arguments that were made
by conservatives about gay marriage just
a few years ago and where we are in
relation to those
it's not just the case that basically
every prediction made by the christian
right about what would happen in america
after gay rights were legalized and gay
rights were normalized happened it's
that like the most cartoonish
strawmanned version of their argument
that a left winger would have come up
with 10 years ago has turned out to be
what's actually child drag chefs yes
exactly like child drag shows and also
uh left-wingers like pink news thinking
that it is bad press for the republican
party for them to go out there and go
did you know that the republicans are
going to try to ban child drag shows if
they get elected and expecting people to
look at that and go oh wow well i'd
better not vote
of course
yeah yeah what a great advertisement
it's just become bizarre and and look i
i still believe that i'm i'm okay with
gay marriage personally okay whatever um
but but
the the stuff that's come from after it
it it's been it's been messed up the the
trans rights has been such a fat you
know weird issue and and i think dave
chappelle uh kind of lays it out nicely
and he's like you guys need to disown
these other people you need to
disappoint
this is the problem this is the problem
there are people like i think caitlyn
jenner has been great speaking up in
defense of uh women's sports people like
blair white i think are fantastic there
is a scientific science researcher a
trans woman who's talked about male
advantages in sports i think you know
look people want to live their lives the
way they want to live i'm very civil
libertarian libertarian the issue is
there are there are bad people who are
trying to cover up their their their
what they're doing by hiding within the
lgbt community and the challenge is when
you call out these bad people
they will use that and that and say
obviously you're attacking trans people
no no that that is a person preying on
on little girls going into the girls
bath and taking pictures of them yeah i
i got no issue with the trans person i
got an issue with the people exploiting
it but you'll get banned yeah
you'll get kicked off but i'm glad that
people like blair and caitlin are are
speaking out against this you know this
crap and we need more hopefully
more like them if there are them
but
well there's just one more thing i want
to say here because i i hear what you
guys are saying i don't think we share a
perspective here particularly on gay
marriage i think once a society says
that two men can be married and tries to
redefine marriage in that way we've
already lost the plot on what gender
roles are and so we're open to any uh
and everything happening with the
relationship between men and women that
doesn't really correspond to reality and
what the the sexes do and how they're
designed to relate to one another that's
a long philosophical moral and
philosophy ethical conversation i think
it's a libertarian like right now we're
saying like libertarian versus
conservative
but let's talk about uh speaking of
terrible families and abusers we have a
story about hunter biden
oh you're ready for conspiracy theory uh
uh conspiracy theories on that aren't
conspiracy theories anymore because we
waited a couple months not even a couple
of months been a week yeah hunter buying
oh this is okay hunter biden helped
secure funds for us bio lab contractor
in ukraine gosh
incredible
russia's assertion that biden's son
hunter was financing biological
laboratories and ukraine was based on
truth now hold on there a minute
bio weapons
i don't know anything about
and that's where the fact checkers keep
coming in because instead of saying bio
labs which we know exists now because
victoria nuland basically said they do
you say that and the media comes out and
says they talked about bioweapons labs
like no no no these are bio threat
reduction labs the us is trying to stop
the threat of biological weapons and i
got to be honest it actually makes sense
the the these programs the funding it
all makes sense that they're they're
investing they're doing research not on
weapons but they're doing research on
pathogens for the sake of being able to
identify and protect against considering
they're right next to russia i think
that makes sense you can look at it more
from a more malicious or nefarious angle
and say no i don't trust the u.s they're
probably doing this we still don't have
any evidence yeah i guess the question
is what kind of research do we know
they're doing there is gain of function
research occurring but we don't know we
don't know anything right right check it
out they say a trove of emails on hunter
biden's infamous laptop found that he
played a role in helping a california
defense contractor analyze killer
diseases and bioweapons in ukraine now
that is a bold statement i'm going to
push back a little bit and say based on
what i've read from this i still don't
see bioweapons but far be it for me to
call the new york post who is news guard
certified wrong
if they're saying the emails show hunter
biden did this and there are other
outlets reporting the same thing then i
can only say i don't know look fact
checkers take it up with the new york
post i'm just gonna i'm just gonna say
you know what it must be a conspiracy
it's all fake news so the new york post
and their conspiracy theories why would
they go and report that
the funny thing is the new york post
reported about hunter biden's laptop
what did they say russian disinformation
then we get the bio lab story what does
the media say russian disinformation you
give it a week what do you find it's all
true you know as soon as we first heard
that phrase i joked
why would we ever believe these people
when they call something russian
disinformation that's what they call
like everything that turns out to be
true and also why would we believe that
when they said anything about a
biological uh weapons lab being fake
news but it's both sides of the
political aisle now it's not just the
democrats saying russian disinformation
uh for example just last week
congressman dan crenshaw was on fox and
friends and rachel campos duffy was kind
of pushing him back saying hey some
republicans are concerned about you know
just jumping on the ukraine you know
bandwagon and giving them everything
they want because yeah we're worried
about pushing russia closer to china
whatever crenshaw goes well uh we're not
fun you know when they say you're
funding neo-nazis that's a lie it's
totally fake news and then he goes and
says the bio labs when you say the bio
labs you're playing into putin's hands
you're pushing russian disinformation
this is a republican member of congress
and
obviously this came out two days ago
it's been vindicated and he has said
nothing these people say nothing they
lie and then when they get caught lying
they never apologize they never correct
their record in fact they double down
and so it's it's dangerous that we're
playing with a nuclear power
like this and i don't know are these
people working to protect the biden
family are they not wanting this
information to actually become the
weirdest public but i don't know the
weirdest thing about this
is that we have confirmation from
victoria newland testifying before the
senate there are biological research
facilities in ukraine or biolabs for
sure
as far as i know tulsi gabbard tucker
we're not talking about weapons now
truth be told i haven't heard every
single thing tucker said but tulsi she
came out like i never said weapons
there's bio labs there and where like
russia might get them is a bad thing
like what's going on there we should
know so they always move the word so
after the 2020 election it went from
there's no there's no voter fraud to
there's no widespread voter fraud right
they always move the word they always
try to change the narrative and they
play a narrative game and and they can
because they have big tech on their side
and they have every mainstream media
publication on their side and so they
can move whatever hell word they want
just to say that we're wrong but i just
i'm just what's confusing to me is that
when you wait a week the story's proven
true
so how are there people who still
believe this like a story breaks you
gotta go i'm gonna wait a week then you
go oh that's what happened but there are
people you know like like bill burr you
know when he was talking to joe rogan
and said i just turned the tv on once
every two weeks and do what they tell me
once every two weeks i turn it on yeah
they do whatever they say hey look at
that he's like oh you know where you
know you're not a doctor you know he's
talking about masks why did he become
fouchy yeah
it's like it's like younger
yeah what are you talking about over
there talk about masks yeah but no um i
think that
maybe i'm being a little optimistic here
but the number of people believing them
are fewer and fewer with each passing
day let's uh let's let's ramp it up we
got the story from the wall street
journal prosecutors advanced tax probe
of hunter biden grand jury heard witness
in february about past drug use spending
habits of president sun let's talk about
ukraine hunter biden was helping secure
funding for this contractor it was
reported by several outlets uh notably
the daily mail that hunter biden and joe
biden shared bank accounts this was back
i think in september they reported this
so here you have joe biden whose son is
on the board of an energy company where
he doesn't have any experience or speak
the language
there's concerns about an investigation
of the founder of that company michael
ischevsky and then there are some
requests you know some emails go to
hunter about like we got to deal with
this then joe biden flies out and says
if you don't fire the prosecutor then
you're not getting the billion dollar
loan guarantee
sounds an awful lot like a lot to me
like joe biden uses his son as a proxy
for corrupt dealings in these countries
and you know what i feel bad for hunter
we keep ragging on hunter yeah he's just
a fall guy for biden right yeah joe
biden
it seems like he says to his son you go
work the private company you get the
salary i can set these deals up because
i'm the vice president we'll share bank
accounts you pay my bills and we'll have
one guy for all of our taxes that's what
they were that's what they were doing
it's been reported
the shared bank accounts thing is a
unbelievably gigantic red flag to the
point where you don't you still share
your bank account with your dad yeah
believe it or not i don't know don't no
no but if i was smoking parmesan cheese
maybe i would have to for for people at
this income level i don't know how they
shared a bank account yeah because the
taxes must have been a nightmare
how would you prove to the irs that this
purchase is like oh well this one wasn't
joe this is hunter because you people
need to understand you can't just give
people money you cannot do that you're a
wealthy person making 83 000 a month
like like hunter biden he cannot just
hand 40 grand to his dad it's not legal
you'd have to do tax filing for like
gift taxes and stuff like that so that's
that that's that's a huge
red flag i mean i'm just
confused by what their system was today
and it's also important to know that it
wasn't just hunter and beau biden was
also involved in the family corruption
and nobody wants to talk about that
because obviously you know me passed
away and that's that's that's tragic and
that's sad um
but beau biden ran a foundation and it
just came out uh
sorry
uh but it just came out in a in a new
report that uh uh he he was in charge of
the foundation they raised like 4.9
million dollars only 500 000 that
actually went to operating costs and the
rest of the 4.4 4.5 million went to
paying um you know salaries of board
members and lobbyists and consultants
and so it's a whole family corruption
it's it's a disgusting family that's uh
done nothing for our country but used it
to get rich do i really have to clarify
that saying i feel bad for hunter was a
joke
no i mean like pointing out this dad's
corrupt and and come on pushing all this
like no hunter biden's a bad guy to be
fair given the way his dad acts around
young children i am not convinced
terrible things didn't happen to hunter
biden so i do feel bad oh yeah yeah yeah
i mean
he's also a crackhead yeah we gotta keep
that in mind
crackheads make bad decisions they sure
do it's true though you know look look
look and and with all due respect people
suffering from addiction who need help
they do make bad decisions regardless of
whether or not you wanna have sympathy
form or not hunter biden man
you know it's really fascinating you see
these people of great power but they
just can't control themselves yeah
epstein
i mean that's why they seek power people
who can't control themselves try to
control the entire world to compensate
for that unfortunately i think in
politics i i talk about this a lot you
know i wasn't a perfect grade point
average student in high school i you
know i was a high school student that
particularly
in high school i yelled gay i tweeted
gay i was a i was a rebellious high
school student but i think a lot of the
folks that end up getting into
washington dc were the folks that never
were really popular in school were never
um
you know they were like the really great
students they didn't really have a lot
of fun and for the first time in their
lives they get into power they feel kind
of cool and then they
take off you know years and years of
misery and anger and then they do bad
things with it and so
a lot of sick people up in washington
because of that i believe yeah well joe
biden was actually a very popular uh in
high school he was a very good football
player it led to him getting the
nickname hands he called him hands right
he's got he's got that do you remember
there was this whole story i think it
was like a children's thing but they
they said that joe biden's nickname in
high school was hands because he was so
good at football he was really good at
catching them and something like that
yeah
well i also heard that he was very
popular with the kids in the pool and
he's got hairy legs
i've heard that too
can you believe that story when he was
like i'd be in the pool and the kids
would grab my leg hairs like what are
you talking about
81 million people voted for that
[Laughter]
dude i i always tell the story of the
people i knew who are like posting on
social media like i did my part voting
for joe biden did you and i'm like
oh man
if only you watched true not a shot at a
pressure in battlecalf care maybe maybe
but these people just they they just
i don't know where they get their
information from they're watching cnn
all day i guess because yeah cnn doesn't
have any ratings no they get it from
twitter unfortunately most of these
people get it from twitter and the
podcast and twitter recognizes that and
that's why they started to break the
game and they they promote you know it's
it's stuff like remember when covet
happened and then they had the trending
tab and the news tab and then they
created a whole separate covet 19 tab
they're basically doing the same thing
with for ukraine now they're just
controlling the narrative they're
banking on people not doing their
research and twitter has become the the
thought box for almost half the country
if not more now it's the crazy stuff
with project veritas too yeah overall
like these investigations and the spying
it's creepy stuff it is but let's uh
let's let's uh let's do something
special ladies and gentlemen we have a
story to talk about that involves me and
uh i have to address it so uh good sir
would you like to talk law with us sure
we have we have a lawyer who's coming in
right now that's correct we got a lawyer
gonna stick me here yeah have a seat and
uh and introduce yourself sure
we have a lawyer
interesting that was weird give me one
second i'm gonna look at that camera oh
no no that's fine oh wait this one's
this is not working
oh okay maybe that maybe that camera
then you want to turn that one on then
what's trying a different camera weird
it's uh uh the powers that be you don't
have to come over here sorry
the powers that b are trying to stop us
from uh from talking about this very
very important issue and hopefully the
camera is framed properly
max headroom yeah the camera wasn't
working uh hello good sir would you like
to
grab those headphones and uh introduce
yourself sure so can you you want to
grab the mic yeah right up to the mic
there you go right up to the mic it's uh
is it can you turn the volume up yep yep
we'll get some sound there we go there
we go now we're good to go all right
all right so my name is jeff clark and
uh
i'm the former double assistant attorney
general in the trump administration i
had 1400 lawyers under me at some point
but in in the interest of full
disclosure i am irish
well i know you you have a habit of
internalizing people's uh sorrows and
difficulties so just try to be careful
so i'd like to uh talk to you guys about
this story real quick and we have a
lawyer give us his perspective um can i
just make one point i want i want to let
the audience know what i referenced
earlier it's from a children's book
called joey the story of joe biden where
we learned that in high school he was
given the nickname hands because of how
good at football he was anyway all right
ladies and gentlemen i'd like you like
you to take a look at this is a
timcast.bandcamp.com
for those of you that are familiar and
those of you who aren't uh i released a
song november 2nd 2020 called will of
the people it's actually part of a
series it's a it's a universe where
we're actually writing a bunch of
different uh songs that go into this
artwork we've got a studio that's going
to be producing the artwork we've got
two sequel songs that are in works we
have we just released the retro version
the beginning of this month and you can
see here our album art shows an orange
sky with statues and cables on it and
they're being pulled down in the
beginning of this song
we can see right here what you're seeing
right now on the screen and i'll
describe it is gears and this is
underground i'll lower the volume and
just play the intro for you
now what you're seeing is the ground
level and the base of a statue as it the
song begins to start to show you
as it moves up
you then see the cables at the waist of
the statue under an orange sky
and more shots of the statue with cables
wrapped around it i then want to show
you the end of the song which is kind of
a spoiler alert for those who haven't
seen this this production but at the end
of the song you then see
the resolution which is the ground level
brown orange sky cables wrapped around a
statue and people are pulling the statue
down but when they do the statues rotate
so keeping those uh points in mind i'll
just quickly say
i produced a song
that is part of a bigger project we're
working on uh you know we've pitched
movies we've talked about graphic novels
we have a whole story arc for the
characters in this because we've been
we've been trying to build culture and
we're trying this is what this is our
most successful cultural thing we've
produced
we have a story
called will of the people it is a song
and series we're producing
and it it begins with a ground shot
the base of a statue under an orange sky
with cables pulling it down
on march 9th which is also my birthday
muse posted this video
which i'm not going to play for
copyright reasons but i can scroll
through starts with a ground shot you
see a foot
some point come in then you see the base
of the statue pointed up with cables
hanging down under an orange sky and
then it zooms out as a hooded figure and
people are firing more cables and they
then pull the statue down
now
my initial reaction to the fact that uh
muse launched an album called will of
the people and a song called will of the
people it was on this show that ian said
to me he's like hey did you know muse
has a new album coming out called will
of the people and i went oh how about
that because yeah it's just it's just a
title and muse being very political i
thought okay you know whatever
then it was last night we were driving
back from you know we're just out of
town a little bit and i decided to
actually take a look because i hadn't
actually looked at what muse was
producing and sure enough
it's it's
uh the way i would describe this is it's
a live action version shot for shot of
the intro
uh and parts of the ending of will of
the people now considering this as a
promo we don't know exactly what muse is
intending to do with the full release
in this video they're chanting over and
over again the will of the people the
will of the people and of course in my
song we say this is the will of the
people and they're pulling statues down
so it's very similar um i've uh what
people need to understand is i've not
said anything in terms of legal stuff i
tweeted out we have questions but
considering we've heavily invested in uh
we've got again i got two songs you know
i can i can actually do this i'm gonna
do something i shouldn't do because i
shouldn't have to reveal this stuff but
i have no problem showing just a little
bit of a rough cut
[Music]
[Music]
so this is uh one of the songs that i
don't know how to turn off
there we go that we've been working on
because and we also have another song
it's on my instagram so we're absolutely
producing in this and this is an issue
for us so i'm
i'm curious mr lawyer what your thoughts
are well uh you know look you know i had
done uh copyright work for uh general
motors at one point about uh the
computer code in their cars
um and attempts by uh the state of
california to uh to grab that so you
know look uh in terms of the basic
elements of of copyright law i mean it
looks to me like
uh there's a lot of similarity here and
uh you know be interesting if you could
uncover evidence of whether there was
actual you know intent to copy uh but it
it looks like it's been you know some
key elements have been copied and then
the the the issue is you know is there
originality in your work i think it's
very original i think particularly you
know compliments to you
the turning statue that was inspired by
artwork from a polish artist but we we
created our own version of it we
animated it and we made it part of a
bigger story okay so this is this is
there's a lot to break down especially
uh some people have said i tweeted this
out and i said we have questions big fan
met bellamy would love to chat because
i'm i i need i need questions answered
right um a lot of people said the idea
of the statues being pulled down you
don't own i said right and they said
this the idea of an orange sky you don't
know they said the phrase will the
people you don't know i said okay and
then i said
the name
the ground shot followed by the base
shot of a statue under an orange sky
with ropes pulling down the statues is
pretty much a live-action remake of what
we made right well look i mean it seems
to me that that's the kind of defense
argument you would face right but it's
an attempt to atomize your work if you
look at it if you take a step back and
you look at how you've combined the
elements right it's combinatorial it
looks like it's very similar and if i
were you i'd be pretty concerned about
uh you know muse
uh you know coming out with something
like that right after you've done it so
there may be evidence that that you know
they saw your work and uh that would be
very troubling if i uh we're looking at
that tim considering that uh matt
bellamy has praised alex jones in the
past uh there's a there's uh maybe i'm
wrong i just want to make sure i can put
that out there but there have been
numerous uh statements and i listened to
an interview purportedly of the lead
singer of muse telling alex jones alex
jones inspired his music
their songs use a lot of themes of
anti-establishment anti-government so a
lot of people like them though i don't
know where they exactly stand on the
political spectrum
it stands to reason that uh
they likely have access and have
definitely seen the work we've done and
produced considering the guests we have
on the show overlap with a lot of what
they talk about so
you know so i've seen them uh you know
uh i know that uh they have a connection
to the alex jones show i have some used
songs on my iphone right behind me um so
you know i i know kind of where they
draw their themes from and i can see why
you're asking these questions if i made
a
wrote a book you can't copyright book
titles right
uh
not quite sure of that off the top of my
head okay uh so
uh i'll put it this way there's a lot of
people who responded to my post on
instagram and my twitter when i said we
have questions i didn't say anything
beyond that i didn't threaten any i
didn't claim anything but a lot of
people immediately said muse didn't
steal your work and like i didn't even
say that a lot of people didn't realize
though that they took the name as well
as the color scheme the symbols i mean
we have the character in the hood
raising his fist and
and then like it's a whole pulling the
mask up
so obviously there's a lot of things
that exist in in in reality that you
can't individually claim
but um you know my response is like what
if i wrote a a book called um star
battles
about space ninjas with plasma swords
that fought the imperials that's awesome
would i get sued
would i get sued for that if i made that
book yeah i think you would because you
know everyone would recognize it as
connected to star wars and
um you know the the combination of those
elements right those creative elements
is what makes it you know a particular
work and you know i i think you'd have
you know an interesting claim uh you
know more than colorable it seems to me
that
uh you know that's infringement of a set
of combined ideas that you put together
and if i didn't sort of spell out the
atomization point right if you just you
know take a very narrow slice of some
creative work you can always find that
there's some similarity to something
else right that can't be the analysis
you have to take a sort of gestalt and
take a step back from it and look at it
in order to assess that kind of issue
so everybody uh
we're we're a decently large company in
terms of revenue
not in terms of employees but uh we're
expanding we've got multiple properties
we're building a new headquarters we
have lawyers we have several because
this is what you have to do when you're
working in entertainment and content and
so
the first thing we have to do as we're
working these projects is just like send
it to the lawyer and the immediate
response we got from one friends who are
who are lawyers and our lawyers was
whoa
now here's the crazy part
they published it on my birthday
now obviously a lot of people the first
reaction i get was like
everybody basically said to me actually
everybody has a small handful of lawyers
they're like you know if someone came
out and said this guy made a similar
work to me and put out on my birthday
they'd be like well you know look
there's 365 days in the year it's like
they're eventually gonna hit it but when
it's the same name
then it's like well you know i guess
okay but then it's the same colors the
same theme similar characters same story
same name and on my birthday yo it kind
of sounds like they did it on purpose
well if you
uh take a number of uh probabilistic
events right and you start looking at
what's the probability of those all
happening in conjunction with each other
right you multiply uh them together and
the fraction gets smaller and smaller
right i mean these kinds of things you
know those sorts of arguments are are
launched in you know all kinds of
litigation but you know especially in
the criminal law right what so maybe you
know there's a one in 10 chance that a
particular fiber you know was left at
the scene of a crime right but then if
you accumulate it with a piece of
evidence about you know the the
ethnicity of the person and then you
have some dna evidence like dna evidence
doesn't necessarily rule out everybody
right but you multiply all those things
together you get to an astronomical
number then you start to scratch your
head and say you know looks like uh the
odds that it's not this person are very
low and so in this kind of analysis it
would be with all these coincidental
elements of the work all occurring at
once seems uh like you're it's right for
you to be asking questions but it
doesn't seem like a coincidence well let
me let me say this to everybody who's
listening live
comment do you think this was
coincidental or intentional and i want
to ask you guys what you think
based on what you've seen and you know
well i want to get a ahead of everybody
else in saying this i think that we've
found out who the muse of muse is yes
it's tim
you are their muse
and and so
i think
jeff's assessment that there's something
there uh it's pretty accurate
jeff would you
when you look at this just personally as
a lawyer does it look like intentional
to you
like it was intentional
you know i i think as a lawyer part of
my training is to be cautious tim and so
you know that that i wouldn't uh jump
out on right now but i will say that you
know like putting those two things side
by side they look pretty damn similar
and there's some other and they're named
the same thing yeah they're named the
same thing i mean
you know uh you know where there's uh uh
smoke there may be fire and so it's
right for you to be pushing this and
raising your questions and the fact that
there's a year and a half
like distance between the two projects
coming out uh like when when you first
post about i thought you just posted it
like create this video like the other
day i didn't realize it was out for a
year and a half like they've had plenty
of time to watch it like review it and
be like oh we've got 1.2 million views
on our song yeah it's it's you know it's
definitely spotify it's on itunes on
bandcamp
uh the first the the first uh tim cast
ira performance of this was june 19th
2020. so even well before we published
the video of it i was playing acoustic
and singing live
so
you know i don't i don't i don't know uh
what i have to consider is
there's a difference between
me as an individual business owner and
what a a corporation with multiple
owners would be dealing with there's
pros and there's cons to being a partner
in a big corporation
let's say you own a company with like
four other people shareholders
you've got 20 someone's got seven
someone's got 30 or whatever
if some problem happens and you want to
stand your ground and say i will not
allow this person to come at me you've
got to consider your other partners you
got to be like who's our investors
somebody invested money in our company
if if i go to battle and i lose i'm
losing their money so you may be risk
averse one of the benefits however is
you get a problem like this and you can
say we have an obligation to each other
and it's not about what we want to do
it's about what we have to do
so if uh if i had multi if i had
investors in this company which i don't
then i would have no choice but to
immediately
launch
fire everything and be like we cannot i
can't be responsible to investors but as
an individual as someone who's a fan of
muse i think about
look we've got a lot of money invested
in this project we're working on it is
it is too similar already when you
search for will of the people it's
displaced us but it's not just the name
it's that it's literally the description
of what my song is their description is
the same as my description for the most
part their their visual depiction and
story is the same if you were going to
explain to someone what my music video
was it was interchangeable between the
two of them how am i supposed to carry
forward with this this massive
investment into building culture when
muse a year and a half after me has
published what i view as a shot-for-shot
remake of at least so far the intro with
the same name of my song
and so the question is
it's it's you know
i'm a fan of the band i can play most of
their songs you know but but this is
this is this is a threat to my business
and to the end to the mission that we
have
i don't have investors to worry about
but i'm wondering what people think i
should do in a situation like this
should we say
we can't
should we say like already mews making
an announcement has generated because
because they're a large and famous
international band already it's
generated so much press that's an uphill
battle for us or do i say we are one of
the biggest podcasts in the world with
60 million view listeners every month
and we have to push back and make sure
we assert our copyrights and the project
we've invested all this money in we've
been investing in this project longer
than they have
so what do we do yeah you know we'll
look let's just look at this you know
from uh you know just for the sake of
argument right like ruendo let's suppose
that they deliberately
uh copyrighted it right
um you know that the
they may have made some kind of
calculation that you know based on
looking at some statistics online
uh that uh you know they they can get
away with this right and so if i were an
individual creator right i'm not uh a
person gifted with a lot of
you know musical uh or you know visual
artistic skills i'm i'm a guy who lives
in the world of analysis and and writing
and presenting arguments to courts um
but you know i respect your talent a lot
um as i said i'm a fan of muse too i
have you know their songs on my
iphone but you know i i would be
insulted if i were someone who poured my
creative energy into something and i saw
that it was you know blatantly being
hijacked that's very that's that would
that would hurt me personally let me ask
you a basic copyright question um
you know a company like warner they're
going to do a basic like search for ip
and copyright if they're launching a
product right yeah i mean they're going
to do any company that that engages in
anything especially if it involves a
significant investment is going to do
due diligence to see you know like
what's out there who who could come
after us
we did yeah when we launched this so we
we we're careful to make sure that when
we're launching it we do basic searches
we look up song we don't find anything
we're like okay we're good you know
because if we're gonna if we're gonna
put tens of thousands of dollars into
marketing even right yeah you don't want
to take chances with it because it
obviously is possible sometimes that
there could be some coincidental overlap
you don't want to be blindsided by that
when you're down the road
in the business venture that flows from
the creative act you know i would think
that that big you know company behind
muse would do that kind of work
um and you know look it also doesn't so
let's say there was again for just for
purposes of argument
imagine that there was some deliberate
activity here it doesn't even look like
they tried to to uh make tweaks to
things to to be able to improve their
position right they didn't change the
color scheme you know the titles the
same
uh you know the the birthday i think
that that would make me wonder whether i
was being trolled but i don't think
that's the kind of thing that you know
that could be pure coincidence but just
all of these things together
but look like both both
videos start with a ground shot there's
a slightly different the shoe steps in
right but then it shows you know the
base of the statue theirs is pointed
upwards mine's the base the the ropes
are already hanging from their statue
the ropes are already hanging from mine
orange sky right people are pulling on
it and then uh that's the cold open and
the reveal at the end is they're pulling
the statue down and it's rotating right
so look
we have no choice but to ask these
questions and pursue it and have these
conversations especially there's a lot
of people need to understand about you
know why we would do a segment on the
show about this
and it's because there are certain legal
questions about your ability to assert
your position when you're a public
figure
uh
long story short is
if i don't exercise my rights to try and
assert my copyright it could be bad for
me and considering we've got two songs
nearing completion and we're reaching
out we're we're storyboarding the next
we've already finished storyboarding the
next series on this
i have to be like hey this is an issue
for us and we're taking it very very
seriously and we're going to be you know
we need to have a conversation with
warner and muse so warner and muse you
need to be talking to us we have to
otherwise
i don't i it has to be done
so with that being said um comment let
me know what you guys think i'm not
saying i know exactly what the best path
forward is for anybody for me or muse or
otherwise i'm just saying
whether you agree or not
most people say there are similarities
there's confusion there's an issue and
ours existed first and we've already put
more money into this so questions need
to be asked
but let's let's we'll move on from this
because i think we talked about as much
as we can and let's talk about the uh
the academy awards
i think that uh um
will smith smacking chris rock was
staged really
what do you guys think i don't know yeah
i have no clue i almost don't care
you almost don't i don't i don't care at
all uh about you know that event that
took place but i think it's important to
talk about uh mental health and you know
mike cernovich has been on top of this
talking about how uh you know
it's probably taken a toll on will the
fact that you know he allows his wife to
sleep with other men and then you know
he's totally okay with that but a joke
uh he he gets upset by and so will's
probably not all there right now uh from
a mental health standpoint and so even i
i could see how it wouldn't be stage i
could see how uh maybe he just had
enough and he had to stop someone did
super chat as saying trust me it wasn't
staged and the way chris rock reacted
there's two things one suggests it was
stage one that it wasn't after he got
hit you could tell that he didn't know
what to do and he was like in a
difficult position where he was like uh
and they said we're giving away
documentaries oscar's because he's
clearly flustered he got smacked in the
face however
when will smith cranks up to hit him
chris rock doesn't put his hands up
which is a common reflex when you're
about to be hit yeah in fact he does a
maybe it was an accident but he makes a
move that is common in fight
choreography where he moves with the
hand swing yeah so when someone is fake
slapping you what you do is when the
hand is coming in you move with it
so it's a glancing hit and less impact
to your face well their ratings have
been in the tank for the last few years
and nobody talks about them anymore and
now everybody's talking about it today
there's been great memes created already
it's a great meme template will smith is
a you know he's i'm very grateful for
his work and giving us good meme
templates over the years um his movies
have been lackluster to say the least as
of late um but he gives us great meme
templates since there's a lot you can do
with the slap
welcome that's true cuck was trending on
twitter all day no really because jada
pinkett smith apparently is allowed to
be with anybody she wants yeah i got to
read mike cernovich's tweet it was the
best tweet i saw on this whole
uh
situation mike's been on fire for this
he's always on fire he he tweeted
being a cuck just went out of style
everyone saw a broken man trying to save
face don't be smacking cheeks when you
letting other men clapping cheeks
wow poetic by cerno
and it's almost ten thousand likes on
that one oh man um
twitter doesn't let me pull this stuff
up anymore but so so look you know i i i
didn't study hollywood fakery in uh law
school so i don't pretend to be an
expert but you know i would say as a as
a lay person i i don't i don't buy this
i think it's about as real as you know
wardrobe malfunctions right in the past
you know and and look they're you know
hollywood is uh expert in uh staging
things right that's what they do for a
living yeah and and so and that's why
the cops didn't come in look and i'm a
fan of uh will smith he's a fellow
philadelphian um so uh you know uh i you
know i i think that the whole thing
smells and it and and it's the kind of
thing you launch when you're in an uh
award show that no one wants to watch
anymore yeah it's possible it was real
yeah like you know you can think about
the lapd said you know chris rock's not
not gonna file so that's it
my response is the police don't need
the victim to file if the police have
evidence enough to convict they can go
and whether or not you you as a victim
want them to
so it could just be
it's all one big happy family and
they're like
we don't want cops arresting will smith
just let it go and they all say let it
go and that's what happens when you're
powerful wealthy elites you can walk up
to a man and smack him in the face for
your wife's honor and
you're not going to spend it you're not
you're going to go party afterwards and
get drunk yeah i personally thought
the clip of
amy schumer and her her fellow idiots
singing gay on the stage was
uh i didn't watch it uh
you got you got to pull that one up you
literally have amy schumer and two
people i've never seen or heard of
before my entire life singing you know
protesting around desantis's bill saying
gay gay it's just so weird that
hollywood would be protesting like the
most milk toast uh attempt at an
anti-grooming bell strange yeah it's
just right but
i mean roman polanski's yeah
you're just jealous again going back to
your detention slip yeah i'm p i i'm
seriously pissed where was amy schumer
when i got sent to the princess that's
exactly right that's exactly right
hollywood's dead man yeah they had uh 10
million total viewers in the oscars last
year brutal and that was down like 60
from the year before yeah we did a
cartoon about that if you guys want to
check out it's called the locust oscars
on freedom tunes i'm not sure if it was
staged i said i almost don't care i
guess maybe some small part of me
does a little bit just because i very
much dislike hollywood and they do
something ridiculous and i want to say
uh
darn hollywood but
whether it was faked or not
it's clear that this has had the effect
of people
ridiculing a specific person at the
oscars rather than the entire ceremony
as a whole because for the past couple
years it's been how unbelievably stupid
is this ridiculous padding of oneself on
the back ceremony that occurs where they
give awards to their friends for doing
things that they sit there and pretend
uh
is important while the rest of us don't
really care
sheamus yeah i would like to award you
our first gosh our first annual
so i want to say
that we have always been ahead of the
curve on tim cass right who wants us
telling ordinary
in telling ordinary americans that
they're wrong and need to be more like
us thank you for this award yo legit i
think i'm gonna buy a bunch of those
little alpacas yeah let's give him
honest awards yeah i think i should go
pick some up sheamus didn't say he
stands with ukraine in his speech
he gave it back to mine again
because i think it is the default stance
to stand for ukraine that's right i'm
sorry that you don't agree if we did
like an award turn it around on him
doesn't need to be said exactly it goes
without saying if we did like an award
ceremony called the truth ease or
something and we use little alpacas yes
do you think you think james o'keefe
would mind that'd be so good james is
great so this is what if what if it was
an award ceremony for like most
contrived speech and we just went to
different podcasters and awarded them
based on who gave a really contrived
speech at some point in their podcast
and then they have to give a contrived
speech while they're up on stage
receiving it i mean who who would be
better for that sounds great is that the
whole point of the award show someone
goes on stage gives a contrived speech a
lot of people get mad at it it boosts
ratings and people pay attention
wouldn't it make more sense to just cut
out the nonsense and give people awards
simply for making contrived numbers
it is a crazy thought when you realize
that nobody watches the oscars these
great cultural moments losing
significance and now we just don't care
anymore we're talking about it now
because some dude smacked another dude
but whether it was staged or not that's
the only thing they have that makes us
talk about it yeah do you know do you
know what movie will smith was in uh no
no no no no
do does anybody know i i know a movie
here isn't the c no i know do you guys
not know no idea king richard yeah i'm
sorry you're up to date on these things
tim no but my point is journalism yes it
is but my point is people don't even
know what movie will smith was in when
he was there and all they know is on tv
some guy smacked another guy that's all
the oscars is these days yeah but you
know
back to the uh i'm becoming probability
guy uh you know back to the combining
probabilities right the fact that uh the
show is failing and the only thing that
makes anyone talk about it is this
incident
to me suggests that the incident is
artificial
right makes sense it's fake news it's
all fake news but uh people need to
understand too that that stage doesn't
mean anybody other than will smith and
chris rock knew about it it could even
be that that chris rock didn't know
about it but will smith's people told
him this would be really good for
publicity for yeah he's we you know we
heard he's going to tell a joke go up
there and smash is he going to get like
an alopecia like a anti-alopecia
contract i don't know we're talking
about this
it's his first oscar isn't it
it's the first one he's ever won i don't
know that i don't know also what was the
joke even gi jane like why is that a bad
joke because jada pinkett smith has
alopecia so her hair's falling out so
she shaved her head
so he was like i look forward to gi jane
too
and will smith laughed and then jd
smith's face like flared at him and then
she looks at him and then he gets up
and then you know chris rock says
something like oh hey richard or
whatever and then will smith slaps him
i thought it was fake i thought it was
fake because the cops didn't come i
thought it was fake because chris rock
didn't do anything
that's the weirdest thing to me
i i don't know if i was on stage and
someone walked up to me the first thing
i would do is be like i put my hand up
and be like back off what are you doing
yeah you walk up to me like this i don't
know though man because if if we were
gonna fake a fight and that was our
whole thing and
you were supposed to come up and smack
me i wouldn't be like yes i'm gonna take
the role of the guy who stands there in
front of the entire world and doesn't
fight back after he got smacked in the
face it just seems like a really weird
thing to agree to i saw all these
comments
defending his wife's honor
and uh who defends their wife cena with
a like an open hand slap
i gotta be honest i think it's good that
we're talking about it do you yeah
because i'd rather people of low um
what's the right what's the what's the
polite way to say this of low cognitive
limited cognitive faculties i would
prefer it if they weren't coming out and
arguing politics and voting for biden
you know the way i put it when i was
younger i was like i wish more people
were involved in politics why won't they
pay attention all they care about is
sports and celebrities then 2020 happens
and all people cared about was politics
but they didn't know anything about it
and so they're like i just feel like
we're in a car you know we're in a bus
and everyone's like we can drive off the
cliff or just turn around and i'm like i
vote to turn around and they're like off
the cliff off i'm like no no everybody
look at the rabbit look out the window
look at the rabbit stop
if people want to pay attention to
politics and they're passionate about it
then by all means we can have
disagreements for whoever we want but if
regular people are going like yo he
smacked that guy i'd rather have them be
more interested in that than going out
and voting on things they don't know
about and aren't interested in you don't
got to be smart to vote i'm not saying
that i'm saying if you don't care about
it and you're only going out and voting
because it's pop culture that's a
problem let's have everybody go watch
sports and pop culture somewhere else
and anybody of any intellect or you know
whatever you're allowed to vote so long
as you want to and you're choosing to
take that first step
you're saying it consumes their
attention span uh you know budget
and i guess i gotta thank will and chris
because they were able to shift the news
cycle away from ukraine for a very short
moment
and so i just now we're back i just
wonder if will smith has some irish in
his blood
that's a great point that that must be
all right let's go to super chats
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends if you like
it and head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only segment coming
up at about 11 p.m on the website and as
a member you're helping keep all of this
work going you're helping us expand and
build that cultural content i've been
talking about we uh i just want to i
want to stress the importance of
cultural content the daily wire is doing
the same thing
because
complaining about stuff on the internet
only goes so far
making artwork content that shows your
values and inspires young people
and will live on
that's important inspiring someone who's
young as to like why should you have
these values here's why here's what we
believe in just saying it isn't enough
you got to show and that's why cultural
stuff is so important so with your
support we'll do more smash that like
button let's read some of these super
chats we got random user who says send
will smith to smack putin
that sounds like something someone at
the oscar's speech would say that's a
thought something something lindsey
graham would say on twitter that's true
man overboard media says can next year's
oscars be hosted by jerry springer and
steve wilkos
yes
amazing
trip sucks says out of all the voices
that sheamus can do he chooses a tucker
carlson impression for his regular
normal everyday voice i sound like
tucker what do you really sound like
here's like here's my actual voice
ladies and gentlemen
the media wants you to think that i
sound like tucker carlson i don't
actually ridiculous i've never said
anything that sounded even remotely like
tucker carlson so why do they want you
to think otherwise that's the question
you need to ask
he adds those little things afterwards
like you know yeah it's like one or two
years instead of just making a
declarative statement he then adds
you know why don't you think about it
well
and they should and they should yeah we
got the irish brogue from you uh tonight
back there it was uh it comes out to me
every now and again because i
internalize other people's suffering so
often white paper cat says you're
working on a video game cool and uh yes
we are we've had a bit of a functioning
like alpha
and then we have uh right now a
we've we retooled it and refined it but
right now the latest version is awesome
i think so i i i won't say too much but
um
you can you collect it's it's a it's
sort of a rogue like i think it's a
roguelike game these ways to describe it
it's a top it's a platformer descending
roguelike where you are battling your
way and collecting new items and uh yeah
this is good stuff in the works i think
i don't know if we ever said the name
publicly or anything though no i i don't
want to give too much away about it
we've been working on this for over a
year and it's sort of gone
yeah yeah we we've gone there's been a
couple of iterations but it looks like
it's finally getting to the final stage
with like the actual code that we're
gonna end up using in the thing so i'm
really excited about it it's gonna be
really we're really getting close
there's definitely more that's like
there's more work to be done but i think
we finally have the the basis completely
finished we're not working on a rough
draft at this point right now it's now
it's a matter of artwork and i think the
only thing we really need at this point
is like
we want to make a ridiculously massive
inventory system
so you know i'm talking like
weekly updates with new items yeah and
it's it's going to be fun it's going to
be fun well and uh tim how cool is it to
be at a show where you got you know
d100s on the dd104 i got a d120 thank
you for that d120 it's heavy too yeah
the d100 won't stop rolling after you
roll it
away there you go
destroy the whole table you got a 14.
14. all that for 14. yeah pretty crappy
all right trinidad a shop at a pressure
says i'm a professional actor and have
been a professional fight director that
slap was a stage slap note will smith
hitting his chest to make a sound did he
really
pull that up did he do that he did the
do you want to pull it up um
yeah i can pull it up in my laptop i
heard that right i thought it sounded
weird i'd heard someone say that he
stomped his foot come on you're telling
me hollywood couldn't come up with
better special effects than that if they
were to fake this really
he did not yeah but yeah but look if if
it was staged between just the two
people and no one else right
yeah
thomas sidebottom says the only reason
the media can get away with saying what
he actually meant was is because biden
literally can't defend against it also i
mean they they do it all the time to
people who can defend against it they
just know what you were thinking every
time you say something it's really it's
very impressive power they have
seriously jk says i know i'm a random
internet guy but i have a very close
inside hollywood source with direct
connection to two of them nothing was
staged trust me or not but this person
is super legit but could it be
that
will smith walked up to chris rock
yesterday and whispered i'm gonna slap
you do a joke okay don't tell anybody
could it could it have been that staged
and so obviously their family and
friends were like wow that was real
huh
maybe
let's see
that barrick bulldog says no ian we
peeing
ian is currently on vacation
tim let me send you the link i i don't
know i can't pull it up on it oh you're
not able to pull it up on there okay
all right i don't know jacqueline pierce
says shim cast please shout out joseph's
nine ninth birthday because he's a huge
shim cast fan in love loves freedom too
so much thank you well that's fantastic
uh joseph is also an incredible name
happy birthday young lad
vosh says zolensky threw up the white
flag he's giving up the donbass if only
russia would have told us that was their
intent we could have negotiated for
peace instead of arming people they
consider terrorists is that happening
that's the latest he's giving up he's
going to give in is it poo does that
make putin stop don't know it's not
going to work
yeah
should
i i you know that joke i sent you about
the usa today article mm-hmm should we
say that or we should did you want to
use it let's use it let's let's think
about it also someone someone shouted
out the cartoon we collaborated on
i think it was very very good i think it
was up there a little bit he uh
complimented your your voucher oh there
you go harry toe says the freedom tunes
episode fauci starving for attention is
the funniest thing i've seen this year
when fauci tim starts singing the eminem
song i almost fell out of my chair
i'm very proud of that yeah that was a
great moment and if you guys are
interested if you watch the cartoon and
laugh if you donate on patreon you'll
actually be able to see tim and i
recording it and some of it was actually
improv the the final product is a bit
different from the script and we came up
with some really funny stuff wait so we
actually recorded when i had that
epiphany yes i was like i stopped and i
was like sheamus you're like wait a
minute i've got it and you're like what
what do you got i was like stan i was
like that's a horrible idea we're not
doing it
fouchy
singing stan
or trump trump trump sings the the dido
part and then
geez
you guys gotta check it out
group b says in response to earlier
video brookings mislabeled you as tim
pool daily show when everyone knows it's
tim cast also about bio labs how do we
know
how do we know that they don't data back
from the soviet union era have data i
don't know but i will say the timpool
daily show is a podcast
i put up two podcasts timcast irl is
conversational and temple daily show is
monologue so uh if you didn't know that
because tim cast irl on podcast
platforms has way more viewers it's like
triple the audience uh
so on you i have two youtube channels
which are like me monologuing and then
that becomes one podcast on itunes and
spotify called temple daily show that's
what brookings was it was referencing
they basically took me saying there are
no bioweapons labs and people are wrong
and then made an article saying tim
poole pushes lies at their bio labs
congratulations that's it's brilliant
fake news
all right
what do we got here
awesome archivist says tim i have a
prediction based upon my analysis of the
ukrainian war i believe if the un and
nato do not help rebuild ukraine for
fear of further russian aggression the
world economic forum will for uh will
for public for good public press
interesting
perhaps
vallorn says see we english told you you
can't trust the irish but you didn't
listen and now you have one doing this
don't feed him whiskey after midnight
first of all
week after midnight come on no way
yeah we have to limit chambers after the
show because we we wrap up around 11.
and then seamus is always going for the
whiskey that's extremely offensive it's
not true it's for it it's true
only when it's not lent right yeah
that's fair
all right
i see icefox says any advice for how to
research your reps people like me who
work long hours and no skill in research
trying to figure out our reps claims
versus actual beliefs i just moved to nc
and i'm trying to figure out my reps
choices so i can vote i'll vote right
coming up uh go talk to them
look at their twitter look at their
twitter talk to them and you can go to
ballotpedia and look up a lot of
information about them
what's the best thing you can do it's
hard to know exactly
how you can can you trust them you know
look at their record i guess but it is
tough to be you know usually there are
some uh rating services that you know
look at people's voting records so you
could find that on the net too
greg duvier says sheamus why do you
still use patreon that's a good question
so we're actually working on building a
paywall on my website right now so we
can use that instead but it's still
under construction uh so i i switched to
subscribe star for a little while but
unfortunately even though everyone tells
you they want you to use something
besides patreon when you create
something different you just don't pull
in as much through donations and it got
to the point where we were literally
going to have to stop making the
cartoons because we weren't generating
enough revenue to continue so i just had
to go back to patreon for the time being
get that website yeah yeah no we're
getting closer it's it's built so
basically what we're going to be doing
is launching a paywall the normal
freedom tunes videos the weekly uploads
are going to stay free but we're also
working on extra content for people who
donate and uh and
a little bit i don't want to give an
exact date right now but once we have a
solid enough content of library to have
a bit of wiggle room we're going to
launch the official website where people
will be able to donate for exclusive
content so we're working on it now and
i'm pretty excited for that all right
hans gruber oh i'm scribbler
he says when billionaires sell massive
amounts of stocks to pay taxes on
unrealized gains the market will crash
that's true
yeah well that's what i'm saying i mean
they're going to have to sell off their
shares you're going to crash the market
but as i also mentioned what you are
doing is you are essentially saying if
someone is doing such a good job at
running their company that the value of
their stock increases they should
sacrifice control over their company to
people who have potentially never been
involved with the business before that's
insane crazy yeah
all right
winston alexander says with an
unrealized tax the government will have
to federalize appraisers local tax
assessors and insurance adjusters
yeah otherwise how do you actually
determine the value of something
crazy man
bd pershing says this hits people who
own crypto hard because you don't earn
any money on crypto till it's sold so
all these multi-millionaires due to
crypto are going to get hit hard
they're legit people who are worth 100
million because of crypto
so they're going to try and stop these
people from becoming wealthy off of
crypto but man just think about crazy
that is
that you're you're some libertarian
trying to buy drugs on the internet in
20 2010 and now you're worth 500 million
dollars
crazy good for them
no yo you think i'm kidding
that's what happened to a lot of people
man
sequoia says unrealized gains tax under
unrealized gains tax force forces asset
sell-offs across all vectors huge
financial crisis fed has perfect
rationale to buy these assets currently
prohibited
they have ownership stake control of
every company equals great reset
crazy man
yeah or they like seize your assets
because you couldn't afford your tax
bill so they just take your stuff from
you without you selling it you know
a bunch of people were arguing over
smashing the like button button the
smash like like the smash button
smash the like button i think people
were saying slap the like button earlier
in the show slap it smoosh where it
started
wealth tax is already here it's called
property taxes my house assessment went
up 20 that's true and uh property
ownership is how people transfer wealth
to their to their kids so they're
absolutely taxing your wealth they just
want to do more it's to prevent ordinary
people from becoming wealthy because one
argument that the left will always make
about systemic racism and redlining is
that property ownership is the quickest
way to build up wealth and either enter
the middle class or upper class and
black people are excluded from that but
they're fine making it more difficult
for literally everyone in the country to
amass wealth that way
even though they have acknowledged that
it can keep a group of people down and
will keep groups of people down
well it's what you were saying tim
earlier about you know structural
dynamism if all these rules basically
lock people
uh you know
lock the world into a stasis where the
rich stay rich and other people can't
climb the ladder then you know there's
no challenge to that economic power
structure and it's just not the kind of
system that we should want to have you
know we need to have
uh strong respect for the rule of law
and for constitutional law but we also
need you know an adam smithian kind of
economic system otherwise you know you
get power monopolies either on
governmental power or on private power
or these days the combination of private
and and uh and public uh power all in
one
all right
wes candle says even if they did get the
idea from you they'd have to steal
actual frames of your footage for you'd
have a claim blade runner used that
color palette with statues and star
battles surely exist
how would you one more time on that one
that one went by too fast i apologized
yeah wes candle says even if they did
get the idea from you
they'd have to steal the actual frames
of your footage for you to have a claim
blade runner used the color palette with
statues and star battles surely exists
uh no i don't i don't agree with that i
think that uh you know it's a it like i
said it's a kind of overarching analysis
that looks all at all the elements
together and you know i don't think you
have to copy particular frames in order
to have a case
stock says wait 10 days and we'll know
if it's intentional or coincidence
what would you recommend in terms of
something like this should you just wait
until they
publish something that may be infringing
or do you
uh well i mean you know it looks to me
like you should raise these questions
now because you also don't want to wind
up in a spot where you sleep on your
rights right that's what people need to
understand i see you know people are
commenting like tim thinks he's all this
and all that's like dude
you have a bunch of lawyers when it
comes to criminal or civil they tell you
if you don't exercise your rights you
can't defend them later on so let me
just warn all of you guys
if you come to this property because
we've had the issue you will you will be
charged with a felony i'm not i'm not
exaggerating the feds have already been
here because of what's been going on and
there are people who think it's a game
so i'm just letting you guys know
we our hands are tied on all of this
stuff
because there's a big company with a
bunch of employees if someone comes and
does something we have to exercise
fullest extent legality uh the fault the
to the fullest extent the legalities
because if there is someone who does a
thing
that in some way infringes or violates
any of our rights and we don't exercise
it we lose claim to it in the future
so with this song our immediate reaction
was we have to exercise all options
right and in terms of your physical
safety right you know with your
employees you owe them you know certain
duties and you know you need to make
sure that you
uh you know don't just sleep on your
creative rights but
you know you you protect uh the physical
safety of everyone who's part of your
enterprise you know what's sad is uh
as as our company grows not a day goes
by where i'm not saying to you know
i'm not i'm i'm not you know uh
i'm not wondering myself or realizing
this is exactly why all corporations do
the things they do
because
certain laws exist uh regulations exist
and it's really fascinating when i
learned you couldn't give people money
that was kind of shocking to me i was
like wow you can't give people money you
can't up to fifteen thousand dollars you
can give someone money but you can't
like you can't like buy your mom a house
so you just can't do it there's ways you
can support your family for sure but uh
there's like you can't hire people
unreasonable at unreasonable rates you
can get investigated
people seem to think that um if you have
money you can do whatever you want it's
like man
certainly it is good to have money no
joke life is comfortable but there are a
bunch of rules that come into place if i
want to be able to make music and make
money off it if i want to be able to do
this show and make money off it all of a
sudden there's crazy rigid legal rules
we have to follow
when something comes out that people are
saying looks like it's a copy
we're like okay we have to exercise our
rights absolutely 100 otherwise we could
we risk you know losing them uh in other
places so that's why this is this is why
and i'll let you guys know
this is why i'm talking about it
publicly on this show instead of just
going to our lawyers and being like fire
away i was like no we should talk about
it let everybody know what's happening
and how we feel about it because we want
to be able to produce content and not be
crushed by massive conglomerates like
warner or something like that that means
we do it this way um
and you know some people say it's it's
you know i've been advised maybe we
should just
file something and not talk about it oh
my god i'd rather let people know you
know what's going on and uh be
transparent to the best of our abilities
but at the same time assert we will be
exercising our rights
um i'm wondering if in 10 days it's
coming out the song or something i don't
know i know the album is released in
august
all right
wes candle says so following up he says
i've worked on tons of music videos and
they were clearly referencing blade
runner i like you tim but no one in this
industry is passing around your music
video for reference
you know i i disagree especially with
people saying i think they were saying
matt bellamy was on alex jones a year
ago or something like that multiple
years ago i thought it was back in 2006.
yeah that he said that he was inspired
by jones to uh make uprising yeah i
thought he was on jones yeah talking
about alex jones's documentaries and
stuff it's been a while so
if this is a guy who's familiar with
this space and he's in politics and he
pays attention to anti-establishment
voices
yeah i think it's incredibly likely plus
the video's got 1.2 million views it's
not like
it's not it's got no views you know
all right raymond g stanley jr says
stand your ground your effing tim pool i
mean look
i i i here's what i want to say too
about the the the people getting charged
uh for coming here that sucks i i never
wanted to be in a position where it's
like a castle like a literal one with
like fortified walls and then you
realize
you have no choice literally legally
criminally civilly we we have no choice
if someone steps foot on the property
the first thing that happens is the
police come down and that person's
getting charged uh and i'll just make
sure it's clear there's big no
trespassing signs you walk past that
it's a misdemeanor there's a physical
barrier you walk around it or pass it
it's a felony not kidding and and
that's all i can say
you know but people people need to
understand that and we do have uh
we
i'll leave it there because
it's it's a tough circumstance i always
wanted to be like accessible we want to
do events we wanted to be like in the
future we're gonna have events that will
be members only and then we'll it'll be
semi-private people started abusing our
kindness people started doing crazy
stuff and the sad thing is when you're
getting 60 million you know we were
getting like 100 million views during
the election it's crazy crazy numbers it
takes only one out of 100 million to be
crazy to come here and ruin everything
for everybody and hurt somebody
so
all right let's grab some more
lex avolino says sheamus fellow
god-fearing brother here building in the
blockchain gaming space would love to
hear more about your game and see if we
can add some value
shot you a tweet i'm in virginia too oh
cool yeah let's see if we can have a
conversation i'm not sure if you're
interested in other stuff with the code
i've basically just been focusing on
like story and art i wouldn't know
anything about the kind of code that
goes into it or anything that might be
associated with the blockchain but if
you want to reach out to tim and his
people if they're willing to talk that'd
be pretty cool so god bless you and i'm
glad that we have other god-fearing
folks out there
we do need uh
we we do need a blockchain stuff so oh
cool yeah great spidgb says if you don't
defend your copyrights and trademarks
you may as well not have them having
reputation for playing aggressively will
this way to other interlopers maybe
mediate but uh but theirs can't coexist
it's it
property rights right you know uh good
fences make good neighbors and so you
know that's one reason why it's
important to make sure that property
rights aren't invaded by the government
which is happening with increasing
frequency and it's also a reason if
you're the holder of a property right
even an intellectual property right that
you make sure that you're aggressive
about protecting it
jerome morrow says you have to
aggressively enforce your copyright if
you don't not only will you lose your
right to do so in the future but you'll
also be showing the authoritarian woke
left an effective attack vector to
sabotage your future cultural works that
counter their influence
yep
that's basically it you know
pew pew trucker says you're looking at
the muse song the wrong way it's a
tribute cover they just want to stand
with their idols
certainly
one way a lot of people have said uh
imitation is the is the greatest form of
flattery that's true but like
if we have been working on these vocals
and like i've been screaming into these
microphones writing songs we've been
flying out musicians some prominent
musicians we've had on one of the songs
uh actually on both of them it's the
drop it's the former drummer from the
offspring so we're not
like
this is very serious we're actually
negotiating with major labels on this
stuff for like guest vocalists and
singers
i shouldn't have to be publicly
announcing our plans to launch this
stuff because of what muse is is doing
um
regardless of whether or not anyone
thinks it's intentional if someone if
someone does a cover song right you know
a cover version of a song that's you
know imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery right but if they're taking an
original idea you have
especially when it's in the kind of
launch phase and ripping it off that's
theft
man
times are tough we wanted we uh
we have a huge backstory for the
universe in the characters of tales from
the inverted world i think i've even
talked about it on the show the the
dictator his name is the wolf there's
posters saying send the pigs to the
wolves the little boy under the bed is
holding a stuffed wolf uh this this the
character's arc is
his parents are executed by the dictator
that they were calling the pigs you know
cochina or whatever and the last thing
this kid had from his parents was a
stuffed wolf toy so as he grew up he
grew up he always carried around with
him had in his backpack and so he gave
the nickname the wolf which was actually
a term of endearment because his friends
knew what it meant he was this
revolutionary but when he when he grows
up and becomes the leader of this
authoritarian regime the wolf becomes
pejorative like we have a whole universe
mapped out for this project and we were
like we wanted a comic we're talking
about movies no joke
almost two months ago discussions on on
feature film
it's frustrating that it comes to this
and i have to now be like hey look
here's what we're planning on doing i
hope everybody knows but uh that's the
reality of it i suppose so we'll see
where it ends up
all right let's grab a couple more super
chats
jason bellick says i work for the guy
who sued lil nos x for copyright you
need an expert on the music industry i
can hook you up
uh i appreciate it we actually have a
couple
and it's really interesting like we've
already had some conversations obviously
like i said our company has lawyers that
deal with this stuff because
you know we distribute a very large
podcast
all right
ry
ryan merce with the mouth says there is
a video labeled as the leaked song from
muse and the chord structure is
identical to your song but it's not
actually a muse song song by oliver
light called revenge well i've i've not
heard that my my concern right now is
with their will of the people promo that
shows like a live action shot for shot
remake so
all right leon's law says why are these
idiot lawyers advising tim to do lol
suits
what's a lawsuit like a lol yeah okay
frivolous laughable suits that won't go
anywhere i i don't think that i've
advised you to file a suit that would be
point number one doesn't i don't think
he's listening very carefully right
second i've even said filing a lawsuit
yeah no you don't what happens when you
argue with a lawyer over the super chat
like i never said if you notice
if you return to
10 minutes uh and 36 seconds into the
podcast you will know what i said
well see people i think you want to
let's replay the transcript
people don't understand that legal
remedies don't necessarily mean lawsuits
like it it could literally be like when
i say you know taking action it could be
like we write a letter like hey can we
get on the phone real quick yeah
i heard you say that you wanted to raise
questions and yeah i also heard you say
that when you said you wanted to raise
questions people immediately hopped to
the conclusion of you know uh uh well
they didn't steal it from you which is
kind of almost like a consciousness of
guilt or the lady doth protest too much
right um so well that was the funny
thing because some people interpreted
that as everybody knows i'm a fan of
muse and they were like no he said he
like he said he wants to chat with him
he wants to get him on the show some
people said that
some people just immediately went whoa
what and a bunch of people responded
saying dude they didn't steal your work
calm down and like i literally said
nothing right so projection
what you know it's a point i was making
before that
when you say something like that it says
more about what your thought process
saw already without being prompted so
that was the law projection
yep yep
raymond g stanley jr says i love the
support of your audience go irl team you
know i thought about this i'm like i'm a
i'm a big fan of muse i can play
you know a bunch of their songs it's
been a while i forgot something but i
can i covered a you know i could play a
bunch of their songs
i've been a fan of them since i was like
a teenager but what i'm a fan of them or
not is is immaterial to
what's happening now
if some people if if they're like you
inspired them or whatever i'd be like if
they did see it and they were like
you know we were inspired by it i would
have appreciated a conversation but but
i i got to say all that's immaterial the
question is
we have to con we have to consider our
rights we have to always pursue
protecting our rights as a corporation
we we don't even have a choice in the
matter it's not like you can't ignore
these things so people need to
understand that it's not often it's not
personal sometimes it's personal
sometimes people allow lawsuits because
they're just mean people but this is not
personal i'm a phantom muse but i'm not
going to back down from this project
we're working on in the culture we're
trying to build and i've been a musician
since i was seven years old i obviously
care about my work just because muse is
a massive you know stadium selling out
bad doesn't mean i'm going to ignore the
fact that there's an issue
we'll see what happens but uh now you
guys heard it from me before anybody
else because i didn't want this to come
out like a press story or something and
then have people be like whoa what's
going on with that being said my friends
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com we're going to
start recording that members only
podcast for you guys which will be up
around 11 or so p.m you can follow me at
tim cast irl you can follow me uh you
follow the show team srl follow me
personally at tim cast and you can check
out will of the people on youtube which
has been up since november 2nd watch the
video it's a short film i think most of
you will really appreciate it if you
like the politics of this show and we
have on my instagram some some demos of
like the the new next songs that are
coming out um on on the youtu on
youtube.comcastcastle we actually show
part of the production process with like
the songs we're working on
some of these are rough cuts and they
don't sound all that good just keep that
in mind and uh the songs are going to
get mastered and they're going to be top
quality really really good stuff so
appreciate it uh alex you want to shout
anything out yeah i can get yelled at if
i don't do that so i have a book coming
out uh it's published by posthill press
comes on april 26th it's called winning
the social media war how conservatives
can fight back reclaim the narrative and
turn the tides against the left and we
talk about a lot of the stuff that we
talked about tonight uh including the
mass formation psychosis that takes
place online uh the censorship hunter
biden's laptop plays a key role in uh
the ringing of the election and so we
got uh we laid that out in there very
nicely we interviewed
dozens of leading conservatives
including donald trump jr charlie kirk
even politicians like marjory taylor
green center rick scott was gracious
enough to give us some time and so it's
an awesome book uh some say it's the
greatest book of all time uh just past
the bible uh and the art of the deal and
so um
unbiasedly i agree with them uh so
winning the social media awards and
barnes noble uh amazon uh all the major
book sellers
sheamus cox
no no you can i'm not gonna mess with
the lawyer all right you know i didn't
have your spot maybe i'll have to
consider suing you shane
oh my god he didn't say he was going to
sue me he said he was going to consider
suicide for everyone listening at home
very good exactly real real quick real
quick someone said in super chats you
guys should call your games division tim
tendo haha defend yourself fiercely
could we do that uh shintendo actually
no no no legitimate question if if we if
we formed a company called timtendo for
our video games i'm not advising you to
theoretically
i i think i'd have to analyze that
question very carefully tim good lawyer
response yes
i kind of feel like i wouldn't get away
with it
especially if we got big nintendo would
be like get out of here you might get a
threatening letter at the very least
yeah yeah
uh you can sue a ham sandwich it doesn't
mean you're going to win that's right so
one thing people need to realize too is
if someone's got the resources and
they're just like i don't like what
you're doing i'll bury you they can just
throw money at you and i mean the
january 6 committee is doing that to you
know to everybody that ever stood by
president trump right now they're doing
that exact same thing there's nothing
that they can be investigating that's
actually legitimate and so their goal is
to financially harm anybody i'm ninety
thousand dollars deep in legal fees
already wow
and all i had to do is tell them to f
off i use the my second favorite f word
fifth amendment 102 times in 46 minutes
i wanted to use my first favorite f word
uh which i'm not going to say because
i'm a classy gentleman right now um but
i mean they're doing just evil things to
evil people i know my friend uh jeff's
also been looped into what they're doing
too but you made a great point you can
sue anybody for anything you can make
anybody uh you know go through the
trouble of getting attorneys just just
for the hell of it and it's a dangerous
tactic it's like poker if you've got the
weight you can pressure somebody and
even force them to back down even big
corporations they'll often just be like
i'll pay you what you want go away you
know yeah and that's what most people
that have been subpoenaed by the january
6 committee have done they've kind of
taken the subpoena and they're like oh
my gosh i want to do what i can
and and uh you know take everything
because i just can't afford it and kind
of similarly to you i think a lot of
people pick on you because they don't
understand how how big you are right you
have 60 million viewers it's a
substantial revenue stream i mean we
were just rated the 25th fastest growing
company uh in the southeastern united
states for private companies and most
people go to our website i'm like oh my
god they haven't they have a wix website
from 2018 which we do we just never
really cared about our website and and
so i'm going to stand up to this
commission tell them to f off because
they're dangerous and they they picked
the i said they picked the wrong fight
and so now if you guys can find the
january 6 committee's phone number call
them and ask them to
drag me in for the public show trials
because i'd love uh for them to do
that'd be a lot of fun uh because i
could use some at least free publicity
with the tens of thousands of dollars in
legal fees i've spent right on wow well
um
i have a youtube channel called freedom
tunes we make cartoons we release one
cartoon every week sometimes two a week
we got one shout out in the comment
section here it's a video tim and i did
about dr fauci he's very sad that he's
not getting the attention anymore so
won't you go over to freedom tunes and
watch the cartoons we just uploaded with
him in them it would really mean a lot
to him and also we did a cartoon on the
oscars from last year uh i was i was
very happy i think it's a funny cartoon
so if you guys want to check that one
out as well i think you'd enjoy it
your microphone's off oh my microphone's
off
yep your microphone's up oh there we go
oh i am there there we go i muted myself
i just wanted to be quiet i just want to
say that our guest jeff is uh was a
former
assistant attorney general for the
environment and natural resource
division under trump i realized that we
didn't fully introduce him he's also a
lawyer which is why we were looking for
his expertise this evening thank you
jeff for pitching in appreciate that
thank you very much i also wanted to say
um we mentioned a website that was for
um
looking for non-woke jobs that site is
down unwoke.hr is gone they got hacked
they were off the air in like a day
which is really kind of annoying but
there's another site called
redballoon.work it's very small but on
it you can go and find like
freedom-oriented employers people who
are looking for maybe unbacks and
employees which is kind of interesting
to me anyway that was just what i found
over the course of the show you guys may
follow me on twitter and mines.com at
cerro platulids i also have sour patch
lids.me where you can go to find all my
socials if you're interested
can i make a quick
plug
so uh please follow me on twitter at uh
jeff clark us
and uh also in light of the uh the
issues that alex was talking about i
have a legal defense fund actually uh
you know in terms of the numbers that
are being mounted up for my personal
legal bills at
givesengo.com
jeff clark
i'd appreciate any help right on we will
see everybody over at timcast.com and
that member segment sign up support our
work and we'll see you all there
you